Three,
two,
one,
boom,
and we're alive.
What's happening?
I,
I'm just stoked to be here because I'm
stoked to have you here.
Man.
It's a pleasure to meet you.
I love your show.
Thank you.
It's fun.
It's a fun fucking car show.
It really is,
man.
It is.
I tell people I might be the smartest
guy in the world.
I figured out how to drink beer and play
with cars.
Paid for.
Yeah,
but it's like,
it's a fun show.
It's like you're not taking yourself too
seriously.
You having a good time,
you know you're buying and selling
awesome cars.
Oh yeah.
For sure.
It's was a dream of mine to get it done.
It took eight years to get it sold,
but here we are now.
Did it really?
Yeah,
it started to.
I started pitching the show in 2004.
We didn't start till 2008 or 2012.
What were you doing before that?
Uh,
before television or before gas monkey?
Yeah.
I kind of had two stages in life.
I was a firefighter police officer medic
before I was old enough to drink.
I mean,
I'm talking 19 years old carrying a gun,
probably want the smartest thing for
them to let me do.
And then I'm to let you know when you
were 19 I had a badge.
I was a cop.
I mean literally I was a police officer
and uh,
so by the time I was $20,
it's also a firefighter and a.
So I did that for awhile and then moved
into printing and advertising and then
sold that and got into this.
So was it just like something you just
always into cars and that's what led you
to the show,
you know,
how would I tell the story
diplomatically?
Um,
realistically I was watching the shows
that were on TV at the time.
I'm always been a car nut and a
motorcycle guy and what have you.
And I realized one night that my kids
are never in the room watching it and my
wife's not in the room watching it,
you know,
and uh,
the shows that we're on,
we're a little bit too much bravado and,
and I'm a tough guy and you know,
so I dug it and all my buddies dug it,
but the wives and stuff and I was like,
golly,
they're missing a big chunk of the
market here.
If you could tone down that part of it a
little bit and still have a cool brand
and still be a cool guy,
you know,
and get the moms and the kids in the
room,
hopefully it's a lot more successful.
And so that's kind of where the idea
came from and I just went out and
started it.
That's interesting.
So the marketing side,
have you kicked in?
So the marketing side of you went,
ah,
I think there's another way to do this.
I mean,
I'm still a tattooed guy with some
jewelry,
but you know,
I got a pit bull or poodle on a leash,
not a pit bull on a chain.
The show,
it doesn't seem compromised.
That's what's interesting about it
because it seems like a kind of a guy
show.
I never thought about it that way.
Well,
the way I approached it was just like
when I was a kid and my dad had a
garage,
a not a not open for public garage.
What do you have plays that we kept his
car and the neighbors would come over
and they tinker and they drink beer and
that's what our guys do.
So we kind of took that approach of
that's what gas monkey does.
We just drink some beer and play some
cars and goof around.
It's just like Saturday afternoon,
but all week long.
Did you have any background in,
in automobile
knowledge?
Did you know,
like how to fix things or did you.
Yeah,
I've never really been the full
fabricator.
Uh,
you know,
I understand everything and networks
works,
but I'm probably more of a business guy.
So I was able to go out and hire good
guys to do the fabricating stuff and
we've got a great team.
But I did have the car knowledge and I
and I had had the eyeball for what was
good and keeping up with what was going
to be happening and things like that.
And that's kind of my strong suit is
saying okay,
Porsche's are fixed to be popular so
we're going to get into 3:56 is or
broncos like the he drove it is you
know,
or what have you.
And I keep my eye on the market.
That's interesting.
But you still do keep your eye on the
market.
I saw that 68 that you have outside of
the 68 Chevelle.
Sixty eight,
68 convertible.
God Damn,
that's a nice car.
It's a good.
It's probably the best one I've ever
seen.
I mean from an original standpoint.
Yeah.
It's meant.
I mean it's got a little scuffs out.
It's,
it's driven,
you know,
but it's,
it's in perfect condition.
It doesn't have any dents or anything
wrong with it is literally a little old
lady from Pasadena.
I mean the lady bought it brand new and
she passed away a couple of years ago
and I bought it from her grandson.
Wow,
what a cliche.
Fifty 2000 original miles and never been
read old lady from Pasadena is a cliche.
It was technically Pomona,
but you know,
same shit.
Wow.
Yeah.
That car,
those uh,
I mean I've said this on the show a
million times.
I'm a giant fan of like the time period
of 1965 to somewhere around like 71.
They fell apart.
Yeah.
Know like you still get a 71 challenger
[inaudible] 71.
Barracuda is still pretty sweet for
sure.
But then you get into like 72,
73.
They had to start putting.
The big bumpers are there with
everything just fell apart and he got
the gas crunch and then everything got
four cylinders and it was,
it was a bad time in the late seventies
for sure.
It was a bad time,
but it's a good time now.
It's a really interesting,
really interesting time now for muscle
cars.
It's the racist,
so crazy that they're putting out street
legal cars you could buy from a dealer
with 700 plus horsepower and almost
every dealer has one now.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
I mean,
I've got a demon myself.
Eight horsepower.
It's fucking crazy.
Now.
The new GT,
$500 out,
that's going to have over 700
horsepower.
You know you have the Camaro l a m,
what is it?
One Ellie know.
What
was it?
[inaudible] one.
Ellie know what?
What the fuck is the name of the one?
Zero.
One one ellie,
which is 650 horsepower and then the new
M,
Z are one at 750 horsepower.
This is preposterous.
Oh,
it's,
it's A.
I think it could be a little dangerous.
You know what everybody out there
thinking,
Hey,
I can drive a 700 horsepower car because
it's completely different than a normal
one.
Well,
did you see the video of the guy from
one of the head guys at gm who took it
on track?
Like one of the first days of the
release in the car and he spun out on
the first
turn and slammed into the wall.
I can't say much.
I wrecked a brand new hell cat the other
day.
Race in Woodward.
Did you really?
Oh No.
I went to Woodward Dream cruise and they
had a little celebrity match up and I
was racing and just lost it and hit the
wall.
Took the whole side of the car.
Were you on a track or where you want to
strip?
It was a street track,
uh,
that they had right there on Woodward
Avenue.
So they put up the blocks and you take
off
those,
uh,
those hell cats are beautiful,
but they're not,
they're not that great at corner.
And that's still a giant car.
Big Car.
Yeah.
Mustang and the Camaro going to do
better in the corners for sure.
Yeah,
the hell kind of so much front.
There's so much out in front.
I mean,
it really does remind you more than any
of those other cars though,
of those 1970 cars,
you know,
really has that,
that shape is more I can like,
if you look at it,
1969 Camaro and then you look at a 2019
Camaro you like,
ah,
I don't see it.
That's not the same thing.
But the challenger really does look like
that old car.
Well,
Kim and Tim can discuss,
killed it.
I mean that was his whole passion
project the whole time he was running
dodge and he just absolutely nailed it.
Yeah,
no they did.
They made a great looking modern muscle
car.
The other ones are just great looking
cars.
I mean they,
they are still muscle cars,
but they don't really think.
You don't really think about the old
days when you see him now.
They've tried but they didn't get it as
good as dodge.
Now you guys make some fucking great
built to,
you know,
you guys have done some really sweet
custom builds like you were telling me
outside that the longest you do a build
for us 25 days a week.
Got It down to about 25 from 32 ish when
we started.
Uh,
so when you see a car on the show,
um,
if it's a single episode that we built
that car in 25,
26 days,
that's crazy.
Start to finish paint interior
everything.
How do you do it so quick?
A lot of planning and we've learned over
seven years now and 130 of them that um,
you know,
we've just got a process in and the crew
that I have at the shop now is
unbelievably phenomenal and there's only
six guys doing it.
There's six guys that do it,
25 days we're done.
That's insane.
But what about like if you're going to
do custom suspension or you know,
art more Morrison Chassy or something
like that.
It just takes some planning.
So literally what we do is we build the
car three times.
This is what I tell everybody will say,
okay,
we're going to build this 68 Chevelle
and so we decide how we're going to
build it and what kind of parts we're
going to use,
what kind of suspension wheels,
motor.
We,
we put all that down on paper and then
if it works mathematically for the
project we want to do,
then I go find the car.
Then when I find the car,
we order every single part and we don't
start that car until every single thing
that was on that list is in house has
been checked and we're ready to go.
So now we've got his actual fabrication
time and human error and we're ready to
go.
Still.
Seems like such a short amount of time
and all the bills that I've seen take
seven months,
nine months,
a year.
It's just the shops are set up
differently.
It may be one or two guys or maybe
they've got kind of,
you know,
assembly programs going on or what have
you,
but we get in there like you'll love the
way we're building right now.
We're building a 77 international scout
and started with a really nice one.
Orange,
white stripes,
plaid interior.
I mean the whole ball of wax whack the,
the chassis out from under it put in a
full Chris Austin chassis works chassis
with only two wheel drive and it's all
2018 hellcat.
Eight speed automatic Jesus in it and
slammed on the ground,
but it's still removable top.
And what?
It was a great California truck,
I guarantee you that.
Oh Wow.
So you made it.
So you lowered it?
Yeah.
We're calling it the health gap.
Uh,
wow.
That's pretty bad ass it.
It's going to be wicked Gar.
Yeah.
Those a hellcat.
Chassies um,
uh,
Jonathan Ward,
the same guy who's doing this is who,
who did my bronco.
The icon there.
Doing that with a one of the.
I think it's a super bird.
One of the,
one of those iconic mopars Yep.
From the late sixties,
early seventies.
They're doing a full hellcat chassis and
the whole deal with that.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Um,
what,
what company was the first one to really
get stupid with these cars?
I guess it was Kinda corvette with the
Zr one with horsepower figures.
Yeah,
for sure.
Corvette guy stepped out there with the
CR one and started cranking it up.
Uh,
everybody was kind of in production.
You had,
you had the resurgence of shelby?
Yeah,
there it is.
There's Jonathan Wards or outlook or
that thing that's good looking.
That is like literally like trying to
have a block,
like a city block on wheels.
They take around a corner.
Look how long that got him thinking is.
Yeah,
that's going to be a fresh card for
sure.
Bad Ass.
He does some awesome shit over there
too.
He's a.
he's doing well.
He's doing one.
I don't think you can talk about.
I think he's.
He's keeping it under wraps,
but he's got a bunch of cool shit.
Yeah,
for sure.
He's never been there.
I have not been straight down the
street.
I know.
Go visit afterwards with my.
I don't think I'm going to make my
flight.
When's your flight?
I don't know.
I've got a couple of Martin hold notice.
I said say I got a couple on hold
because I don't think I make enough
money for a plane yet.
Going to talk to disco and that was like
a private plane,
is that what you're saying?
Yeah,
I don't.
I mean we're all scrambling for
something.
Yeah,
that's the ultimate scramble.
The private jet money,
but that,
that is just so much fucking money.
That seems ridiculous.
Yeah,
but I'd like to have a tricked out one
gas monkey on it.
Big Old monkey on the tail gas with a
keg in it somewhere.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Now when you do these shows and you
bargain people down and then they
watched the show to people ever get
pest.
I've had a few.
And uh,
in the first,
uh,
first few years they were just excited,
you know,
that we were going to be doing something
with the car and it was always an
element of a,
of a sentiment to it,
you know,
it was their dads or their moms or
grandmas or whatever and they want to
see it go to a good home.
So you got several different kinds of
people.
They want you to not do anything or if
you're going to fix it up,
we want to see it,
you know,
all kinds of things like that.
But nowadays it's a little more harder
for me to get a decent deal because,
because we will know the success of the
show and I show up and they're like,
oh,
you're that guy on TV.
Not,
I didn't say $10,000.
I said 13.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well I would imagine when people see
what you sell them for after you fix
them up,
then they get a little upset.
Yeah,
they can.
But I mean they don't understand the
amount of work and time and money that
we've put into it.
Most of the cars that we're building on
the show now,
we're putting elite 100 grand in and
sometimes as much as $300.
Really,
you know,
I mean we're building everything we're
building now.
When the new season comes out in June,
people are going to be amazed because
we're building this kind of stuff.
Wow.
It's wicked cool when you're doing that
in 25 days.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
Just put together a good plan and
execute it.
Well,
it must be like a thing now because the
show that people want to get a gas
monkey bill car.
They do.
But um,
how would I say this diplomatically?
If it weren't for employees,
vendors and customers,
business would be great.
So we,
we,
uh,
we don't do a lot for the,
the customer,
uh,
until we built it for ourselves and then
we sell it to them,
but as far as coming in off the street,
we just liked building what we want to
build,
honing our skills.
And then we find a buyer every once in
awhile I'll have god come in and go,
look,
I can,
this is what I want,
but I can,
I won't call you.
I won't come in there with a new
steering wheel,
you know,
it's like,
it gets.
That's why a lot of times cars do take
seven months or a year or cause the guy
that's happened,
it's built is in there every other
weekend going up.
I don't know,
maybe we move this over here and paint
it purple.
Oh yeah,
I get it.
Yeah.
No,
it does seem like it would be way better
to just build it.
How you like it and then sell it.
Well,
yeah,
I mean it's still a business decision.
I'm trying to build it to where I think
it's gonna do the most,
you know,
the most money at the end of the day and
stay true with what's going on as far as
that particular car and what's going on
in the marketplace and technology and
what have you.
Um,
and we do get a lot of calls where
people come in and go,
okay,
I want that exact same thing and so
we'll build another one.
Well sometimes you do buy cars and then
just sell them without doing anything to
it,
right?
Yeah.
That's what we call our bs stories.
Will buy something and bring it in.
Maybe just put some wheels on it or
whatever.
But usually it's just clean it up,
get it running,
sell somebody else's dream because not
everybody can afford a fully built car
and slash or they want to do it
themselves.
So we get them a good project.
I don't think people realize how much
money is involved in a fully built car.
Like if you ever seen those revegy
mustangs.
I was looking at those last night.
It was pretty intensive build.
Really,
really interesting stuff.
Has got to take.
It's,
it's essentially not really a mustang.
I mean it's kind of licensed by Ford.
It looks exactly like a Mustang and also
a mustang parts,
but he's got everything new is just
brand new,
like a brand new suv.
You take the kids to soccer except
really fast and fun to drive.
And 19,
66,
65,
66.
He's got a GT 3:50.
That's a,
it's not really a 66,
GT,
3:50 every part of it.
All the fenders,
everything's all newly fabricated steel.
We're going to do that this season to
where I'm going to build a car back to
the original,
like a 60.
I was sad.
I'm going to do Mustang or if we're
going to do a Camaro,
but there's this guy's cars.
I mean,
come the fuck on.
That is beautiful.
Well,
we're going to build one that never
existed.
Look how pretty that God damn thing is.
He's killing it.
I'd want to see what one of those things
is like in real life.
He's even got pushed.
Buttons start,
you know,
um,
it senses when you're near the,
uh,
the car.
So it will unlock for you,
but it's the just,
it seems like super high quality built
to mean look how fucking pretty that is.
The trick is,
is how much work goes into it because
yes they do make these parts aftermarket
and what have you,
but a lot of times that's not the best
stuff in the world.
So you ended up fabricating that and
massage and it in and making all the
gaps right.
And so you can't just expect that you're
going to buy a set,
a new,
a new front end it vendors and hood and
everything going to work out perfect.
You're going to always have to massage
it and get it right.
Well I've been paying attention to this
guy for awhile and essentially what he's
been doing is honing the process over
the last few years and he's got a
company now that makes a thing,
it's called dynacore that makes all the
parts.
They make everything in terms of like
the body's body stamps.
Yeah.
And you know,
he's got his whole process down,
but you know,
when you watch them drive the cars,
it seems like he's.
I mean it,
it sounds perfect,
like everything inside of it seems like
completely locked down.
No squeaks and rattles is really like a
modern car for sure.
And there's a lot of shops that do an
amazing job at doing that stuff.
That's what I like,
what I don't like.
I mean I liked the way they look.
If I look at like an old,
like a 67,
gt 500.
I liked the way they look,
but if you try to hit the brakes on one
of those things or if you try to make a
turn with those old tires,
everything's fucking that skinny and you
know,
the balance is all wonky.
Nineteen 67 car balance.
We get a lot of that.
I've built a few cars for,
for a contest and somebody when they're
like,
oh,
I want this car,
and then they're like,
it's,
this is horrible.
I'm like,
that's because it's a stock 65 bus thing
and what have you.
Because if you don't realize what you're
buying and then yeah,
it can be a disappointing process.
Yeah.
Those old cars man mean we've come a
long way.
It's,
it's pretty amazing if you go back from
1970 car to a 2019 car and you drive and
you hit the brakes
and he do all the numbers like stopping
60 to zero and handling.
I mean the cars of today are pretty
ridiculous.
It is absolutely amazing.
The technology that's out and the fact
that we can use that technology so much
easier.
I mean you can build these kinds of cars
or anything you dream up because you can
literally do it right here with your
google and your pocket.
Yeah.
Okay.
I want to do this and this and what have
you.
So it ends up being the cars that we're
putting out are definitely just like a
brand new car yet,
but it's a really interesting time to,
for Resto mods because so many people
are into that now.
They realized that they liked the looks
of those old cars,
but they're not really into the way they
drove.
Correct.
Everybody's about comfort and Bluetooth
and all that kind of stuff.
So I'm not really that way.
I'm a 32 ford nut and I kinda like cars
the way that they more or less came out.
I mean I'm all for maybe some disc
brakes or safety or whatever,
but I like the squeak it and having to
learn how to drive it and figure it out.
And the character of transmissions.
Exactly.
Yeah.
How much longer before the manuals dead?
I think it's already got the nails in
the coffin.
Seems like it.
But then,
you know,
like American cars,
they'll come out with cars like the GT
3:50.
You can't even get it with an automatic
fuck off.
Yeah.
They won't even sell it to you.
And they're going to hold on with that
as long as they can.
But you know,
your big competition cars,
porsche,
Ferrari,
Lambo,
Mercedes,
that you know,
it's,
you can't get them in a manual.
Wow.
Everybody wants that nurburgring time.
You know,
want that super fast nurburbring time.
And unless you have a double clutch
transmission,
unless you have paddle shifts,
you're going to miss a second here and
second there and then people are gonna.
Look at it when it's so ridiculous.
The people that look at those times,
Jack is the average joe it and going out
there and doing that.
I mean the modern cars mean like the Zl
one that we were talking about earlier.
I think they're down to the one lie I
think is down to a seven minute and real
low seconds Nurburg green time,
which is fucking crazy.
That's faster than a gt three Rs from a
couple of years ago for sure.
For $60,000 car that you could buy the
Chevy dealership,
eh?
Probably close to 80,
but yeah.
Yeah,
I think it's like 78.
Okay.
Yeah.
But they're loaded.
But nominal car,
it's,
uh,
I agree that that corvette and probably
the demon or,
or two cars that are the most bang for
the buck.
I mean just get in and go to zero.
One in or the Zr one rather is almost
too stupid.
It's almost too ridiculous.
It seems like if you're a regular person
and you,
you buy that and you try to take it
somewhere for you to understand the
limits of the grip,
how much gas you can apply for you to
have an educated foot.
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean,
I,
those where they first started making
those.
How was it seven or eight years ago?
Maybe a little longer.
I had a client have me get one.
He brought it back the next day scared
to death because I just sell it because
I'll never drive it.
He does that.
That is just stupid.
Yeah.
I saw a picture of one the other day in
my Google newsfeed that someone had
bought and wreck the next day.
Smashed it.
I was just reading today.
Uh,
uh,
somebody sent me a link.
Uh,
did you see the episode where we built
the [inaudible] look at that fucking.
It's fucking wicked.
I'm doing something with that right now
that,
uh,
I guess I can imagine everything you see
there,
the styling,
the,
the carbon fiber points,
the lift in the front and everything
that we
all have it,
but we're doing it with a 72 river boat
tail.
What?
Yeah,
it's going to be frickin sick.
We've already chopped the top and
brought it down so that it doesn't have
that clam mouth and looking windshield.
And so we're taking all of the bunch of
our styling cues in our and definitely
all of our driving components ideology
and we're cramming it into a 72.
Ruby,
how has that fit?
Huh?
How's that going to fit?
Well,
we're not taking the chassis and putting
it over there and we were making our own
and we've worked with Chris Austin on it
also using that transmission,
that independent suspension.
Whoa.
A independent rear.
Got a video.
You're a faggot.
Isn't the 72 riviera like a million
pounds.
How much is the thing way?
It's a lot,
but we're clearing all of that out.
We're working with a speed core and
we're doing a lot of the tops going to
be carbon fiber and so will the hood
trunk and maybe even the full front clip
speed core did a nasty 1970 Mustang for
Robert Downey junior that I just saw
online the other day with a supercharged
coyote engine in it.
Like a weird color to like a beige,
like a weird kind of yellowish,
funky,
funky colors.
The crazier the better.
Yeah.
I just let it.
Like the art car is going to be like a
weird,
muted gray with a red and chrome and
Carmen and I mean we're,
we're getting pretty crazy with it.
We were about halfway through,
so it's a 72 boat tail Riviera CV and
find one of those.
I'm trying to picture that.
I have.
I had a riviera when I was in high
school.
No,
I didn't have to skylar.
So yeah.
Here you go.
Whoa.
That's a stock one.
But then it'll turn into what?
Look at that.
We just started chasing it.
Yeah.
So that's a,
you know,
a few people have built them into hot
rods,
but wow.
If you stay on that video,
it'll just feed to where what it's gonna
look like when it's done.
Oh,
I see what you did.
So you have.
Oh Wow.
That is crazy.
It's gonna be nuts.
It'll probably be at sema this year in
bare metal.
Whoa.
That's a beautiful car.
Don't have wagon wheels on it.
Like that stupid thing though.
Yeah.
I'm not a fan of those,
those uh,
that was a thing for awhile.
That's going to be pretty,
pretty bad ass.
Pretty ass.
Yeah.
You don't see those now.
You never see that car.
Like that's a rare car now.
And we found a one owner with zero hits,
zero rust.
I mean the metal launch.
That's perfect.
What are those Australian cars that were
in Max now?
Woo.
Damn.
That is going to look pretty nasty.
It's going to be slammed like that and
it's got to be nasty to.
We're probably going to bring him in for
around 1300 horsepower.
We're building that one just for sheer
shits and giggles of her phone because
nobody does that.
Well.
Someone who's going to want it for sure.
I hope they have a lot of money.
That's like a money pit right now.
Yeah.
How much does something like that cost
to build?
Three 50.
Wow.
Yeah.
To build.
And then how much would you like to make
what you want to try to.
I always try to make at least 20
percent.
I mean,
it's kind of a goal,
right?
But uh,
that's reasonable.
Yeah.
Especially considering all the creative
time and putting them together and yeah,
we do everything in house.
I mean it's,
except for interior,
we're doing every single thing in house
now.
I mean we've come a long way since the
beginning.
And when you have that kind of
horsepower,
what kind of rubber you're going to have
on that thing?
Oh,
it'll have 15 inches on each side.
It'll have,
I think we went with 24 hours and 20
twos and super,
super wide.
Wow.
Yeah.
You kind of have to.
Right.
And even then,
it's probably gonna spin out everywhere
now because we're using all the
technology,
we're using the independent suspension,
we're using all of the sensors,
all the stuff that's in that brand new
vet application control as well.
Wow.
How do you adapt that over to an old car
like that?
You just go through the systems.
We've got a guy working for us now that,
uh,
helped us run our standalone hill
hellcat that they said couldn't be done
when we were.
We built a sharp cat and uh,
so he just gets the whole thing and
starts eliminating sensors or adding or,
you know,
and we ended up with all the same
technology.
So the sensors understand when a wheel
spinning and then they compensated with
breaks or horsepower breaks,
you know,
they'll get your stupid stupid light,
you can't do that.
You've got.
So we'll be able to turn it all on and
off.
Just like a brand new car.
Oh.
So will you have different modes,
like a race mode,
street mode like that?
Yeah.
But what a lot of people try to do that
I can't stand is they'll take the
something with that idea and they'll go,
okay,
I'm just going to pull the body off and
cram this under there and welded
together and hope it works.
And we make everything adapt to the old
car.
Still work though the way it's supposed
to.
And I'm brand new car.
Yeah.
I've seen,
you know,
there's a,
there's a guy online that has,
I'm on instagram gt 500 super swap.
He took a,
an old gt 500 body and put it on a gt
500 from a modern chassis and piece it
together like that.
But I was always thinking with a,
with a setup like that,
you probably can't have airbags,
right?
You can.
There's actually ways to added into
there.
But you get into the air.
It is,
yeah.
You get into the geometry,
uh,
in the direction of the airbag.
So beautiful.
That looks so.
Yeah.
But you don't want to play with the R
and d of trying to put an airbag into
something like that unless you really,
really know what you're doing because
you don't know refraction of an inch off
of,
of being where it needs to be.
That airbag could do more damage than
good it.
It's weird though because you're dealing
with a totally different size body too.
So I wonder how he's doing this.
It's easy isn't.
It?
Doesn't sound easy,
but it is,
isn't really.
Have you done that before?
We haven't,
but I,
I,
I understand the process and really it's
just got massage,
move in,
move out,
you know,
because there's a company called Mag
Motors.
You ever heard of them?
I don't think I have.
Go to a MAG motors.com.
They have a.
What they're doing is they're putting a
carbon fiber body on a modern gt 500,
but they're using a 67 like eleanor
body,
but they're making it out of carbon
fiber.
So it's a.
That one's gross.
Go to the silver.
One white one looks to hate the eleanor
body.
So you're really overplayed.
How dare you?
It's just,
it's just been done so many times,
but who cares?
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Go.
Yeah,
that's,
those are the images,
but go to get it,
get it from the side so you get a better
look at it.
That's a beautiful car.
See?
To me it sits weird.
It looks like it sits a little too high
and it looks like they're worried,
like I don't know anything about them,
but to me looking at it it's like you
need to get it down a little bit,
get a little more agitated,
get a deeper dish on the wheel.
Um,
well I think what they're doing is
trying to use all the geometry of the
modern car.
Correct.
So you ended up with something.
It looks like it could go four wheeling
a little bit,
right?
Yeah,
it's not,
it's definitely not slammed.
Yeah.
In terms of looks right.
Yes.
I mean I'm sure the car runs and drives
and performs unbelievably,
but it's missing a little to me it's
missing some.
Um,
you know that our company,
classic recreation's never seen them.
No,
I don't think so.
They do.
They're doing similar cars like that
too.
But they're doing it from the ground up.
There's a lot of people doing it because
it's with technology coming the way that
it has,
it's,
it's not as hard to do as it used to be.
Um,
it's still the laborer's task,
don't get me wrong,
but you know,
you can make all those systems work in
anything and see a guy like you that's a
car guy.
You look at an eleanor and you look at
it like it's played,
but a person who doesn't see them all
the time,
it was not in a car industry.
When was the last time you saw one of
those fucking things on the street?
Shit,
I would never say Jackson.
There was like five of them for sale.
That's the thing if you go there,
but like fusion motorsports there,
there are down the street here.
They make,
they're the only licensed dealers.
They have some deal with the woman who
was the,
she was the wife of the guy who wrote,
gone in 60 seconds or producing or
something like that.
And so they make a car,
go to fusion.
Eleanor.
They make some pretty sick once.
But you think there's a plate out
personally?
Yeah.
I'm just not an eleanor car fan.
That is fucking beautiful.
Why do you hate America?
Richard?
How could you,
how could you not love that?
It's just there's hundreds if not
thousands of them out there.
Come on,
Bro.
You must say to America,
no way,
man.
Currently,
and I love the mustangs.
I've got three of them,
myself included,
a real 68 shelby.
But uh,
um,
is it the shape or the color scheme?
I think it's the shape.
I mean,
to me it's,
it's such a popular car in the movie
that,
you know,
too many people did it and now
everybody's doing it and it's what have
you.
Yeah.
But I mean,
how many of them are out there in
comparison to like say a modern Zr One?
It was probably nearly as many of those
thousands of those.
I think so,
yeah.
There's different companies making tons
of them all car people say that they say
to cars that they think are played out
69 Camaro's and these things,
like everybody does a 69 Camaro and
everybody does.
Eleanor and the,
um,
the dukes of hazzard card.
Oh yeah.
Same thing.
Yeah.
Now a bad ass 69 charger.
Don't get me wrong,
but painted orange with a flag on top.
That's played out.
You can't do that anymore.
That flag.
It's fucking
for sure.
You believe they pulled that show off?
The air did?
Yes.
Because the flag that shows off the
showed on like some weird obscure cable.
Jim pulled it off a TV land.
That's TV land.
I wrote a whole thing about it on
Instagram,
how ridiculous it was and I don't know
if I agree with that.
I mean it's like trying to erase history
or whatever.
Yeah.
Well you live in Dallas though.
It's a little easier to get by with a
confederate flag and towels.
Oh yeah.
We don't have a bunch of Matcha tea
drinkers and what have you like we do
out here in California.
I,
you know,
living in Dallas,
I have to do my business with the people
out here in La and it's,
you know,
I'm getting off work before they've had
their two chai lattes and walk their dog
and showed up to the office.
I'm like,
come on guys,
get up and get to work and I get accused
of like,
have you been drinking?
And I'm like,
yeah,
it's 7:30 in the night here.
I've been off for two and a half hours.
People get upset at you if you've been
drinking?
No,
when I'm trying to conduct some of the
business calls that we do in the
evenings because they haven't gotten to
work yet.
And they asked you if you've actually
been drinking sometimes.
Really?
Well she's.
Because they know you from the show.
Well we all,
I'm talking about my agents and managers
networks and whatever.
I'm like,
yeah,
because I've been off since 5:00 eyes.
Most people have a couple beers and sit
around the shop.
Well,
most people there.
Yeah.
It's a different world out here.
A little bit of a culture shock.
It is A.
I don't,
I don't know.
I mean,
I like it.
It's okay,
but I think if I was going to move a gas
monkey anywhere,
it would probably be Scottsdale.
Scottsdale is nice.
It's freaking cool.
It's about a million degrees in the
summer though.
You ever go there?
But it's a dry heat and
sauna.
It's fucking preposterous.
We went outside.
I was in the,
it was in Phoenix last July and we went
outside.
We just stood there for a second.
Oh,
this is.
This is ridiculous.
We should get used to this because this
is what global warming is going to be
like an la a few years.
Yeah.
You guys are going to either be on fire
from the,
from the volcanoes or global warming or
whatever or sliding into the ocean,
but I really like Scottsdale.
Fun Fact.
Next week they have any plan in the
Scottsdale opening,
the Waste Management Open in the
celebrity program.
Oh yeah.
Do you golf?
I absolutely suck at it horribly.
I've been a member of the same country
club for about 19 years and I probably
played about 50 rounds of golf in my
life and they've caught me playing in
the pro am the celebrity thing and
unlike we've ever gets teamed out with
me as in big trouble.
You're going to tighten up before you
go.
Are you going to take some lessons or
anything?
No Way,
man.
I'm sweating because.
Because the way I look at it as,
oh,
I'm going to do.
Then it's like be pissed off that I
can't do what the guy told me to do.
You're going to get much better.
And then it's like what I tell them on
it,
but on top of that is I'm like,
okay,
you think you're so good at golf because
you can shoot 72,
you know,
or whatever.
Well,
mathematically this is an 18 shot game,
right?
You can figure it out mathematically.
Yeah.
I mean if you had some insane ability.
Well yeah,
but you don't have to have in st ability
to figure out the mathematics of it.
So because it's an 18 shot game guys,
but no one's ever done that.
So how is it an 18 child game?
Just mathematically
is a one punch fight?
Well,
no,
it's more like saying that because more
fights are one punch fights than ever.
A golf game is an 18 shot golf game.
I'm saying mathematically propulsion
direction,
etc. And so forth.
You cAn get that ball from that spot to
that whole thing every time it's
possible with enough power,
right?
Yeah.
But in what have you.
But that's literally like saying every
fight is a one shot fight.
No way.
Why?
Because a lot of fights are one shot
fights,
but there's never been an 18 hole game
that's played with 18 shots,
but there are whole ones.
So all you need is never happened.
That was of the human race.
I think the most I've ever done in an
actual real tournament is to.
Someone's done to I think somebody down.
I'd have to look it up.
But uh,
Yeah.
So one shot fight,
they'd probably be,
you fighting me,
you just hit me and I'd go down.
There's been quite a few in the that
I've called one punch and the beginning
of the fight,
bam,
someone gets hit and they go down at
least three or four in the history of
the fai.
Duane ludwig like six seconds.
First.
First punch you through.
That probably made me.
We already talked about working out.
So you're not to go down pretty quick.
I can't believe you've never worked out
ever in your life.
I really haven't.
I mean I'm just thinking about starting
more,
like just cardio and stuff.
I turned 50 in two months so
you know,
I am a little bit.
It's weird number,
right?
It's a weird number.
plus I look at my dad and you know,
he's 23 years old than me and I'm like,
god,
I got 20 years left.
holy shit.
Yeah.
Well working out definitely holds off
the grim reaper a little bit.
Oh yeah.
It keeps your body working better,
but it takes effort.
You got to be willing to do it.
Well,
like I said,
I just hope things work out.
Just hire a hot trainer.
Hire a chick that's going to you.
You'll be motivated.
Who are embarrassed,
you'll be embarrassed and that will get
you motivated.
is chicks like looking at me going,
what is wrong with you,
man?
Are you kind of man?
That is some embarrassing shit.
What a chicken lift more than you.
Yeah,
well I'm sure there's a lot of.
Oh,
there's a lot of them.
There's a lot of them around the block.
Yeah.
Well,
right around the corner is a giant
fucking bodybuilding gym for chicks,
for guys,
for everybody.
Right.
It's just savages.
I dunno.
I like an athletic build on and grow,
but I don't know if I want her to have
giant muscles and yeah,
there's a,
there's a point I wanted to take bigger
crunches than me.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a point where it gets creepy.
There's like,
um,
yeah,
rollover,
holding her from behind little spoon and
I'm like,
oh,
this set you joe veins,
right?
Like veiny forearms on chicks.
Like something about some,
about like veiny chest,
like a girl with a veiny veiny pecs.
Yeah.
No,
no,
it's,
it's a mistake.
They're not supposed to have pecs
anyways.
Just that boobs.
Yeah.
But they have boobs combined with pack,
so that's where it gets real weird when
they have fake boobs,
but they also have back muscles and you
can feel the muscles underneath the fake
boob.
Like this water balloon that's floating
on top of his cgu.
Yeah,
that's too crazy.
That's one thing I do like about
California.
You know,
the,
uh,
the southern California little blonde
with all the tattoos and you know it.
A little bikini on the beach.
One ab.
You take out those in Texas though?
Not as many.
They don't.
Yeah,
we got them,
but not as many.
I'm on instagram too much.
it seems like every girl from Texas on
instagram has tattoos all over the
place.
Yeah.
But that's,
you know,
there's 20 of them.
Not 100,
right?
Yeah.
Out here,
this thousands.
They're everywhere.
Go to like venice Beach.
It's hard to find a girl doesn't have a
tattoo that's unique these days.
That's a real rebel.
Yeah.
Girl with no piercings and no tattoos.
It's either rebel or boring.
Probably both.
She's rebelling against being exciting.
I think the girl bodybuilder though,
what happens is people get into
something and they forget how weird it
is for everybody else.
So as they get deeper and deeper into
it,
they just want to excel at it and they
want to lift more weights and you know,
they're trying to put more on the squat
rack or they're dead lift in their neck
gets big.
And,
and,
and uh,
I had
a girl that worked for me for a long
time that was real into.
She was like this.
Uh,
I don't know what competition she does,
But it was body sculpting and stuff at
this girls over there measuring florets
of broccoli or to scale.
That's when they fucked up.
One little.
Oops.
Yeah.
Once they start measuring their food and
counting their macros,
like settled down,
once you're in some gigantic
competition.
Cheers.
Cheers sir.
Fixing breakout some tequila for you in
a minute.
Break it out,
man.
We have cups.
Oh yeah.
you brought cups to list.
This guy comes prepared.
Oh,
you have gas monkey tequila.
get the fuck outta here.
You got your own tequila.
Dude,
can I get a gas monkey tee shirt?
You have one I brought you on.
I fucking love that logo.
I got some of this crap down here.
Did I put one on right now?
I don't give a fuck to look at that.
Ooh,
got a couple of them here.
That jamie.
Huh?
Nice.
Cool.
Yeah.
You guys have like a whole apparel line.
Do we have everything?
I mean we've got tools.
We've got.
I saw a bathmat the other day at like
home goods or something and I'm like,
I don't even remember it.
Proven that
is it for sure.
Yours.
it's a licensed product.
Well that's part of the thing,
right?
You guys came up with a cool logo.
Yeah.
ANd the monkeys,
you knoW,
he's that lovable character that's also
a pain in the ass and kind of in there
messing stuff up all the time.
But you can't shoot him because he's
just,
that's what he does.
And What happened.
So we did the gas monkey sentiment
tequila.
This is a,
it's cinnamon.
Yeah,
it's a 100 percent blue.
A gavi.
Just swirled with a little bit of
cinnamon and nice.
My kids got a soccer game after this.
I'm going to be fucked up time.
Well salou,
it's good way to get through the game.
Yeah,
for sure.
That's actually good.
It's good stuff.
Don't tell I'm ron white,
but I think your tequila is better.
He'll get mad.
You get mad at me.
He loves his tequila.
We came up with this because this is the
only tequila over finances made in
America.
Really?
Because you have to do sco,
you know,
real blue golf.
A tequila is always at your America from
elise co to get around that.
I ship it in and tankers and then I do
it here.
So we're switching built.
Our distributors are just distillers
right now and will be made in Texas.
So you can't grow it in America.
You can't grow the economy in America.
You could,
but a real tequila just like champagne
in France,
you know,
real tequila is always from elise go
area and what have you.
How weird is that?
It's like burgundy,
right?
These from your burrito burrito.
Exactly.
But uh,
that didn't,
that's funny.
I didn't,
I,
I kinda,
I guess I kind of knew that.
I didn't think about that.
That's weird.
Can make anywhere.
We're literally sold out right now
worldwide.
Yeah,
I took it to the troops.
We went and did a deal with the px
exchanges on all the bases in the world
and they wiped me out and so we're
having to make it right now.
We're completely sold out everywhere.
That's fucking great.
I had to borrow a couple of bottles from
somebody with hoarding them.
That is a fucking dope logo though.
That monkey with the tongue hanging out
that you have that on the outside of
your garage.
You get a bunch of looky loos and find
out where you guys are.
Oh,
we do it on purpose.
We've got a little spot where people
come by and see the cars.
We've got a building there and then
we've got a a merch shop,
and inside the mertz shop you can go in
the back and there's like a party area
where you can have a,
don't sell beer or alcohol,
but you can have a gas monkey energy
drink or water and that will be like
you're in the experience and you let
people just come on down and say hi,
get dressed.
Yeah.
Now everybody can come out.
There's probably were on earth camera
right now.
Pull up earth cam,
gas monkey.
We can see how many people are there.
Do you get stopped by weirdos because of
the tv show?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know what really freaking sucks in
Texas.
This is no bullshit.
I didn't find this out until we got
random.
What really sucks.
Somebody comes on my property and
they're weird and I got to tell them to
leave or they're aggressive or whatever
and I'll get the hell off the property.
Get out of bed for the next 24 hours.
I'm responsible for them if they like,
if they leave and get run over at the
corner or whatever because I made them
leave.
I forced them from the property.
They're my responsibility.
What?
It fucking sucks.
So if a guy shows up drunk and you say,
hey man,
you gotta get the fuck out of here,
and the guy leaves and gets in a car
accident,
he could say,
hey,
they made me leave.
Yeah.
You know,
so the drunk ones,
I'll put them in an uber,
but I'm talking about just the crazy
ones.
You know,
we've got a homeless problem in dallas.
It's starting to get to be about as big
as you guys are having here.
And they'll wonder onto property and
were like,
hey,
you got to beat it.
And then if they go down the street and
gets hit,
yeah,
I'm responsible for their medical bills
can be.
It's the stupidest freaking law and the
planet.
What waS that like a hospitality law,
like what's,
I don't sell alcohol,
but it's because I'm a business and I've
made them leave.
They came to see me and I made them
leave.
They didn't leave on their own accord,
so we have to call the cops to get them
to carry those people out.
That's so weird.
I went to jay leno's garage and he's
telling me that,
uh,
you know,
jay leno's garage,
not jay leno's garage.
Jaylin was 11 garages.
Oh,
I know.
I've been there.
I've done the jay leno show.
It's written daisy.
I mean,
I knew that guy was a car nut,
but I didn't know the magnitude until
you go and you see these 11 warehouse
buildings,
just full,
full cars.
He's got a real problem now.
He's got a great problem.
He's a great problem.
I'm only up to two buildings.
I need to start adding buildings.
How many cars do you personally own?
Um,
iT's hard to answer because I've owned
gas monkey and so we have inventory.
I have to,
I tell everybody,
I usually keep between 50 and 60 cars
that are yours that are sort of for
sale,
you know?
So there's some comes along,
man,
I need that car.
and you're like,
there's a map,
there's about 10 that I won't sell,
period.
What won't you sell?
I won't sell my thomas crown affair
mustang shelby a couple.
What Is that?
A year?
60 eight.
You could probably find a picture of
that on the net,
but it's a,
it's a remake of the one they used in
thomas crown affair with pierce bronson
when he's on the Island and it's got all
the.
I never saw that moment.
It's all lifted on bf goodrich.
Never seen appears bronson movie a dude.
Thomas crown affair is a remake of
another thomas crown affair movie.
And uh,
uh,
the mustangs just wicked cool.
So I had a client,
a friend of mine had me build it for
him,
good friend.
and I wanted the car.
Of course I couldn't afford it then.
We didn't even have the tv show yet.
And so I built in this perfect
rendition.
60 eight shelby convertible mustang.
Put bf goodrich is on it,
raised it all up high.
I mean it's perfect California cruiser.
And uh,
then when I got the show I call him up
and I go,
hey,
can I borrow the car buddy?
Cause I want stuff sitting around the
shop that,
that I built.
I don't want other people'S stuff here.
He goes,
oh yeah,
man.
Just sit in the truck down to pick it
up.
This is three years later.
I send the truck down.
It gets back.
The cars got 42 miles on it.
It's been sitting there doing nothing in
his garage.
He's down in new orleans,
so it's got some of that haze and shIt
from the salt air and gas is there.
It is.
The gas is bad.
Oh wow.
That is really high.
It looks like you're going four wheeling
in that fucking thing.
What is going on with the tire on the
trunk?
That's the spare.
Um,
I know,
but it's,
that's an odd placement.
That's just how it wasn't a movie.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
And uh,
god,
leah,
my fat there are.
What is that?
You?
I don't know.
That's not the one I built that,
that's another guys car.
So I'm just not quite right.
Mine is more absolutely perfect to the
movie.
That's somebody else's rendition of it.
Um,
but anyways,
I called my buddy,
I go,
let me borrow the car,
et cetera.
It gets there with 42 miles on it after
three years it doesn't run.
The gas Is bad.
Carpenters all fucked off and of course
I called him and go,
you're really shitty car owner.
I said,
this thing is freaking bad ass.
Look what you've done to it.
Well,
he has a considerable amount of money,
so the next day the title shows up in
the mail and he goes,
you're right.
I'm a shitty car owner.
Chairs.
He gave it to you.
Jesus christ.
It helps to have a close friends that
have a lot of cash.
Massage,
obviously like you to god.
We're real good friends.
He's.
He's a.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Well,
I want to see what it actually looks
like without the fat guy driving.
No disrespect fat guy.
Yeah,
looking at it Because I could see where
if you don't work out at all,
how do you stay thin?
Because you're a thin guy.
I got.
It's just metabolism.
I do eat right.
I don't eat fast food,
but you drink.
I don't do sodas.
I haven't done sodas or anything like
that and two decades.
And how often do you drink every day?
DoeSn't that cancel out all the uh,
no.
Sodas?
I don't know.
I mean maybe it says it doesn't have as
much sugar,
but you must have like a beer drinkers
metabolism.
You just,
you know how to do it.
Yeah.
It's,
it takes a lot of practice to get to
this point.
Your body's ready.
I'm ready to go the fuck to do.
I was like a marathon runner.
Like everybody can't run fucking 15
miles a day with someone who runs 50
miles a day.
Can do it.
Yeah.
I,
there's,
that's one thing that's just monotonous
to me running my,
uh,
my wife's a runner and a,
I'm like,
that's just silly.
Like why do you want to get out and go
run 20 miles?
I don't run 20 miles,
but I run hills a run for four is the
most I run,
but I run like pretty steep hills.
There's your car,
is that the one that's the same fat guy
right there,
jamie.
There's a couple versions of it and a
lot of the websites are pulling.
Dropped down to the one right below
that.
Where your cursor that there is,
that's the real one.
It's that one right there.
Yeah,
that's a not zero and yeah,
it was a nice car.
It's so much fun and I a bang in stupid
sound system in it.
So you know,
it'd be borrowed the whole deal.
It'd be a great carter cruise around
California.
What kind of engines you put in that
thing?
Just the typical small buckets of gt
3:50.
So it's got a small block,
three or two and um,
what have you.
it's a pretty fun time.
We get to a lot of heads.
And then we were talking about cars.
I wouldn't say I got that.
I got a 52 fleet line.
That was the first car we ever built as
gas monkey garage.
What does a fleet land?
I don't even know what that is.
It's a,
you can type in 52.
Fleet line gas monkey.
It's a,
the fastback version of [inaudible].
Fifty two chevy kinda has the slope
back.
Some people call it a torpedo back.
A look at that thing.
Yeah.
The not that one.
The picture on the far corner.
Yeah.
That's us.
And uh,
it's all patina it out and kind of,
you know.
Oh,
so you kept it like that?
Yeah.
That was the original body.
We chopped it though and it's got a,
uh,
people love that.
Like the original patina it out body,
like I'm icon does that,
they call them derelicts.
That's a good picture of the car.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Derelicts.
And then we got a lead ops we have,
I got my first car I ever bought.
I won't sell that as part as the first
one I ever bought for me.
What is it?
Five,
nine,
nine gtb 2009.
Oh,
that's a nice car.
Super good car.
And uh,
you know,
then I had a couple of other friends but
I'd probably sell those,
but that one first one just probably
never will.
And just because it's like a benchmark,
like you,
I'm a big proponent and believer in
forcing yourself,
you know,
and so forth sell it to,
to want more to do more,
to,
to give yourself motivation.
A lot of people just save and save and
save and I'm more like,
okay,
I'm going to do something that I
probably shouldn't do right now so that
I know I got to work hard to make sure I
don't have to give it up.
I'm wiTh you.
Yeah,
that's me.
I talk my friends into that shit.
I talked to my friend tony into buying a
corvette when he can't afford it.
Taught my friend brendan and about a gt
three rs.
So it's the same thing.
I mean,
I bought the car when I probably
shouldn't,
but the show was going and I was like,
this will make me work hard on this,
you know,
it sits in the corner when I'm doing it.
I get up in the morning,
I look at it,
I got it.
I got to make sure that I can afford
that,
so let's go do it too.
And I believe in that wholeheartedly and
people say you're ridiculous.
And I go,
yeah,
exactly.
Well,
when I was young,
I was a.
When I first got into printing and
advertising at shit,
I could barely make rent.
I think I was buying my suits it,
you know,
a resell shop,
but I would go to neiman's and look
around and you know,
and,
and think about what I was going to buy
it.
Just putting the motivation in my head,
you know,
I guess there's a big movement now with
making your imagination board or
whatever.
Well,
those people are assholes.
Yeah.
My shit just wanted to reel in your head
that I had that vision board.
I get it.
If you're 20 and you're doing that,
you don't know any better.
My vision boards,
you know,
the old poster of the rock band with his
weed and you know,
it looks like a great mission.
Yeah.
That's the real vision board.
I,
yeah.
I'm a big believer in doing this is what
I say to someone who can buy.
If you can actually buy a ferrari.
I'm like,
listen man,
if you don't,
who will,
if you're an 18 year old kid and you got
no money,
and he said,
man,
find enough to buy a ferrari.
Oh god,
I'd be so happy I'd buy that thing.
Well,
you should do it if you can.
You can.
You should do it.
And is it,
is it too much money?
Yeah,
it's,
it's definitely too much money.
That's part of the whole part point of
the whole thing.
Correct?
Yeah,
it's,
it's.
To me,
I use it more as motivation.
I know,
can I afford this?
And then if you.
If terrell chef.
No,
you go,
well then I'm going to.
I'm going to afford it to figure it out.
Exactly.
I feel that way about everything.
So do I.
That's been my mantra forever.
That's people are like,
oh,
you know,
you got lucky.
I worked my fucking ass off my whole
life.
Well you definitely got lucky.
He didn't get hit by a meteor.
You got lucky for a lot of things.
Lucky he didn't get home invaded.
You got a lotta lotta luck.
Luck.
But I'll tell you your,
your,
your past guests of mr.
Elan musk there,
he kind of ruined it for us because now
we actually have a possibility of
getting in a car wreck and space.
Yeah.
You could get in a car wreck and space
because that car is just floating around
out there.
What if that car slams into a fucking
alien?
Spaceships is coming to save us and elon
musk just frivolously shot that fucking
thing in the orbit.
He did.
He just shot it up there and they'd let
him with a robot sitting in the front
seat.
You know?
We were joking around about like,
what if that guy in the front seat is
actually a guy who fucked his wife and
he decided to kill that guy and stick
him in a fucking space suit.
Shoot him into orbit.
See,
I don't get that.
Why do you want to be at the guy if he
does that?
You got to be mad at your wife.
I agree.
I'm with you on.
I'm with you on that to be mad.
If I came home and a dude who's banging
my wife,
I will listen bro.
I get it.
You go,
you gotta go.
You're to.
Depends on what he looks like too.
I mean,
if he's like aqua man to her,
I'd tell her I get it.
Yeah.
Sometimes you got to do that.
But uh,
but uh,
yeah.
Oh,
we're going again going again,
bro.
This doesn't.
This devil sneak up on you.
I could getting snuck up on since the
eighties.
Solute
per.
Ooh.
It's so good though.
It is good.
It's smooth.
I like the cinnamon too.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And it's funny drink for a real tequila
enthusiasm though.
Is that like sacrilege?
Is that like an electric mustang?
Oh yeah.
But that's what the monkey has always
done.
You know,
it's like a play on the golf thing.
I decided to launch gas monkey golf
apparel line and so I'll be wearing a
golf shirt out there and It's pretty
crazy.
It's got a skull and all kinds of crap
or whatever.
But uh,
where I'm pushing the envelope as the
monkey is,
our tagline is snap and teas and filling
holes.
Now when you bring that to the country
club,
do people say,
sir,
that attire is unforgivable here.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
I've been thrown out of my own country
club plenty of times.
He really.
And I've bought a lot of golf carts
because I've crashed because I thought
it was fun and thrown out of your own
country club a bunch.
It's really for what?
Just raising too much hail,
you know,
almost like the old rodney danger
movies,
you know,
it's like,
sorry,
you can't do that in here.
And I was like,
oh,
I'm going to do it twice.
Caddyshack all time.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Now what did they say to you?
Just,
you know,
they usually just take me home because I
live on the course,
so they'll drop me down there.
So you,
you have a house on the course?
I did.
I lived downtown in dallas now.
But uh,
I'm the worst one was I decided to drive
my harley home on the golf course.
One grass.
No,
I stayed to the cart path.
I'm not a complete asshole.
but uh,
I did drive it home at about 1:30 or two
in the morning in my house is probably
the furthest house from the clubhouse.
And that thing is frigging loud when
you're in that,
you know,
this trench of a golf course.
Right.
The cops were waiting on me when I got
home,
but thank god they were reading the
cops.
I was like,
you can't do anything.
I'm going inside fate.
Golf course cops.
Yeah.
You know,
the community cops,
community cubs.
That's adorable.
I had a good one for you.
I actually got arrested at this country
club.
Well,
at my house for it.
I wouldn't say arrested Because they
ended up letting me go,
but they did come cuff me and put me
away.
Um,
the um,
we're coming home uh,
from a christmas extravaganza,
which I do with my buddies every year.
Right before christmas we get a big
garden pile in and we go christmas
shopping
for our families and what have you
coming home loaded.
I supposedly through a burrito from taco
bell or something and hit the guard.
So there's four,
three or four of my buddies.
We get to my house,
we pig out on shitty taco bell food,
you know,
until everybody passes out.
And the next thing I know the cop lights
are on banging on the door,
get out of here.
I come to the door going,
hey,
why?
You know,
after you've been drinking,
did you do a bunch of food?
You're fucking gone.
And uh,
so long story short,
they said,
well,
you're going to be arrested for assault
if you don't get at it and say you're
sorry to this guy salt with a burrito.
Correct.
Right.
And by the,
so if you charge a man with a salt
because he throws a burrito at you,
you should,
you should turn in your card.
But if we were to tape it was not like
throwing it at him.
It's not like I've barely with a
baseball right here.
I like chunked it to him to eat,
but he didn't see it coming and so I
slapped him and Fell down.
So they cuffed me.
They take me down to the guard house.
Yeah,
they put me in the back of the cop car
coffeecake oh,
these are real.
It's so real.
Yeah.
He fileD a report and so this is how
stupid it gets shaped by then.
I'm so fricking loaded.
Right.
And I get there and the burrito stiLl on
the ground,
I'm like,
it's evidence or some shit.
And they're telling me I got to
apologize to this guy and all I can
focus on is there's a perfectly good
vegan burrito.
I'm going to eat this burrito.
So sit down and literally start eating
the burrito and you're like,
please just tell her you're sorry.
So you go back home.
And I'm like,
okay.
So I tell him I'm sorry I'm still eating
a burrito and they just left me there
like a mile from my house at the.
You walked home with mild drug.
Do you see the guy since then?
Oh gosh,
no.
I was like,
dude,
that was perfectly back.
This was in the days before the
sprinters are so popular.
So it was like a stretch limo,
which is,
you know,
you just really don't ride it anymore.
And I was like,
that's a hell of a shot.
Came out of the back window,
120 inches up to the front,
hit the gas squared,
the fucking chest.
I should get a medal for that.
Assault
might be a plus in here.
Assault with a burrito is probably the
first time we've had that.
And you're a little a podcast room.
I definitely think it's the first time
it seems like you'd just be able to say,
hey,
I just throw it to you because I was
drunk.
I thought you were hungry.
This is really what it was.
This is what I mean.
You can hear me on the video going,
hey,
you want a burrito?
And uh,
it was pretty ridiculous.
The guy got a bankcard yang for sure.
Yeah.
What someone calls us salt,
like how dare you.
Some people get beaten to a pulp and you
call him a taco bell burrito flying your
way.
That thing costs a dollar 99 dude
and it's barely meet.
We were going over like how much of
a ruling on how much meat.
It actually has to be where you can call
it a beef burrito,
but there's fillers
in that shit.
Like what is the filler was like
silicone or something like that.
But it's something ridiculous like 34
percent of it is not actually meet.
That's why.
I mean that was 10 years ago,
80 percent for the internet.
They can pretend it's me.
Well,
the cool thing,
taco bell now starting to open all their
ones up with bars inside there.
What?
Yeah.
Well that's good for business to get
people more drunks.
I don't care where the food tastes.
Exactly.
Get them all tanked up,
feed them some burritos and send them on
their way.
Haven't even taco bell in decades.
It's been since then I have some real
legitimate because we're in la.
You're in Texas,
but there's legit mexican places near
you,
I'm sure.
Oh yeah,
but like there's legit tuckerias here
where you know,
you go in there and mexican soap operas
are playing.
Nobody speaks english.
You got to a point this shit and say
thing.
You gotta roll your r's language.
Language idea.
Yeah.
You to speak the lingo.
See I can't do the linguists stuFf that.
The tongue,
right?
Yeah.
I can't do the shit.
Don't ever have it.
I have tried everything.
I mean.
Oh man.
You gotta try elk tongue tacos.
I just.
Why For fucking delicious.
So good.
It's the,
it's the most.
One of the most tender meat you could
ever have.
Like the most tender Pot roast ever.
Really.
It's amazing.
If I ever get a chance,
there's a place right here on canoga,
like maybe a few miles away from here.
How good is that place,
jamie?
When I come to California,
I'm not trying to get some elk tongue.
I promise you.
Well,
I'll help tons in the freezer.
But the cow tongues what they have out
here.
Yeah.
Calton elk tons mined.
But a language case,
ideas,
you know,
you don't fuck with that language talk.
No,
and I don'T do the uh,
whatever that milk drink is,
what do they call it?
Oh,
horchata.
Yeah.
Know which hat is rough because you
know,
there's no fucking safety standards that
no one knows what's in there.
It's like really shitty eggnog and
eggnog is shitty.
It's at least six percent is too at,
for sure,
depending on who's working there and how
disgruntled.
Yeah.
Um,
but you do cardio sada right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I've got a,
I've got a couple of bars and
restaurants down in Texas and so we sell
a lot of tex mex.
Fusion tex mex is a different kind of
flavor.
It's a different thing.
yeah.
Like people that don't know,
like a what a keto is,
you know,
like case.
Oh,
in Texas it's like a staple.
Correct.
Yeah.
Out here.
No one knows what the fuck case.
Oh is he?
I want to get some and chips.
So like what the fuck are you talking
about?
Any trade shows does a few places.
Okay.
So legit.
A real good legitimate lotus and the
corn with the a's and the.
Yeah.
Cream in there.
I could get doWn on some of that for
sure.
Texas is a different fucking country.
It really is.
Well it where I'm at now in dallas,
uh,
literally I can go to the corner gas
station and there's a lady there just
saw on the corn off the cob and puts it
in the styrofoam cup and squirts all the
crap in there and I can make
myself sick on that stuff.
Yeah.
There's tea.
I'm wondering what texts y tex mex is so
much different because there's no
California max.
Right.
But tex mex is.
I would never allow that word to be said
anyway.
California max is probably just pissed
off.
Seventy 2000 people.
That's just a regular podcast.
He said,
California mix.
Try ordering.
Lat line is Mexico asshole and he's
stolen from the mexicans.
Exactly.
know what do you think about this wall?
Bullshit.
Opening little.
Those poor people in here give them
jobs.
I don't give a fuck.
tax it.
Yeah.
I.
I mean I don't want criminalS.
I don't want criminals coming through.
How do we filter out gang members and
criminals?
Just.
I wish there was a way to tell there was
a way that there's not.
I wish there was a way to tell whether
someone's a piece of shit and a
criminal.
I wish there was and or someone just
poor because there's a lot for sure.
Both sides are right.
This is how I look at it.
For sure.
The people that don't want criminals
coming in here or.
Right.
For sure.
the people that want border control to
keep out gang members and drug dealers
and evil people there.
Right?
100 percent.
Look,
I'm.
I'm a fucking american taxpayer.
I have a family.
I fucking salute,
right?
I,
I believe in the law.
I believe in all those things,
but also my,
my grandparents were immigrants.
All of them,
everybody that I that is related to me
came over from europe.
They all came over from Italy and
Ireland.
All of them.
They all came over because their
livestock,
they want a better place.
If someone walks here from Guatemala,
they don't walk here because they're
lazy.
They walk here because they want a
better life.
This kid,
america's made for it,
so I say let them in.
I say let him into,
but I wish there was a better way to
screen out the ones.
If there was a better way to screen out
the real shitty human beings to stop
that would be.
That would be ideal.
We need to cut screener screeners.
The way to go.
I'm going to tag that doesn't exist
right now.
One of my people are listening.
Make sure you buy that whole thing that
all these fucking government workers are
getting paid right now because of a
wall.
Oh jesus.
And this is a billionaire.
Donald,
you believe in the wall that much.
Take $5 billion out of your fucking
account.
Shove those shackles towards the
billion.
How much do they have anything?
They say he's got three,
but it's all paper.
I think you're right.
It's like smooth ones and zeros
somewhere.
It's like his hair,
but you know what?
We elected him.
We got to deal with it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and in our case he was the better
choice,
so he was a better choice of this is why
he's the better choice because to
realize that our system is completely
hosed it like
that.
This guy could get in there and build
that wall,
lock her up and everybody's like,
check.
It's.
It's a.
It's a good.
It's a good example of how our system is
the best,
best system in the world for sure.
This whole experiment and self
government is the best on the planet
earth,
but without a doubt.
But this guy,
it's not his fault.
That is who he is,
but he exploited it.
He showed everybody.
He showed everybody the holes in this
fucking goofy system.
I know,
but he's a reality star and that can be
president one day and you could you and
me
the ticket,
if logan rawlings ticket,
we,
we could win and I'm not bullshitting.
You know,
we could,
when I could do that too.
They did some fucking vegas odds and
they found out that I have better
chances of winning then a lot of people.
That would be fricking rad.
Yeah.
There's like a whole list of people who
had better.
Just like throwing them out.
I got this,
but it's,
you know,
I mean no one's gonna work.
The most fun in that I'm having,
right?
This second is not even in this room,
so I'm managing my pr person or back
there to fuck up on talking about
politics.
See,
I don't have one of those.
My manager is awesome and my pr person
is nonexistent.
So let's get round three going.
Let's go.
Here we go.
Salute.
Marika.
Woo.
I'm telling you,
it just keeps getting better.
Yeah,
it does.
Keep getting better.
Good whiskey or tequila or whatever the
fuck it is.
I forget now.
Yeah,
to politics or the.
That is the one thing that people say
you shouldn't talk about,
but I like,
isn't that what helps us to talk about
it?
It's just that people are so fragmented.
People fragment out everything you say.
And they're like,
well,
you know,
it's like,
it's like you said something,
but then they turned it into this one
little sentence going,
wait a second.
He said these two scripted averages in
this fucking noun and verb and look at
what he said.
He said,
screening.
Yeah,
you heard him.
I told my pete,
what about cut screening.com.
I don't know what I'm going to do with
it,
but we're going to use it.
Well,
if we could just figure out a way to put
microchips and everybody will know
everybody is what everybody did and that
way we'll know if you're a cut.
He walked past this little thing and it
goes beep.
You'll walk by.
He throws burritos,
but he's a good guy.
I'm going to get 50 cars a.
Well,
a lot of them are for sale,
but uh,
we have some pretty cool stuff in there.
Um,
but I'm a big 32 ford guy,
so I've got all the 30 to 40.
What is 32 four.
Why does that one?
Because that's like,
um,
to most guys like myself.
Anyways,
that's what started the hot rod
movement.
They were cheap.
They were plentIful.
The guys came back from ww two and you
know,
they bought a $20 32 ford and stuffed v
eight in it and that became the hot rod
scene and right because like in 47,
32 ford was like the old used car that
he bought that thing for like 20 bucks
and maybe even 10 or five,
you know,
now we're paying $50 for one that needs
everything.
What was your fIrst car?
my first car was a 73 mercury comment.
My first car was a [inaudible] 73
chevelle.
Well that's way cooler than a pIss green
mercury comet.
I promised last I drove it from,
the guy bought it from,
I got it home and the next day the
engine blew.
That's operator error.
No
shit box.
It was just terrible that a six cylinder
straight six cylinder.
So it wasn't fast,
it wasn't cool,
it was,
it was piss green from the seventies and
it was pea green interior and uh,
you know,
the ladies didn't like it and it had the
squeaks and stuff,
you know,
going,
I'd be pulling into high school and
going over the speed,
but I was like,
shit,
this is not cool at all.
But by the time I graduated,
because I always worked hard,
mowed yards,
rake leaves,
whatever I could do.
Um,
I was a hustler.
So by my senior year I was driving a 77
bandit,
trans am.
Woo.
Now the lady started paying a little
more attention.
That's legit.
Those cars are still legit.
Those bandit trans ams,
that movie just revolutionized trans
ams.
It revolutionized a cars in movies when
you had burt reynolds on your car,
on your show,
rather.
I have to say that I got sad when I saw
him walk out.
I was like,
oh man,
that's burt reynolds baggies that broken
down.
You know,
he was really bad broken down at that
point in time,
but towards the end of his life,
he came back kind of full circle.
He was a whole different kind of person
about a year and a half,
two years later,
how,
I don't know,
but he,
I don't know if he was just going
through a bad spot,
but towards the end he was hip.
Cool.
We did a lot of different things
together that you'll see a real,
you know,
and uh,
what have you.
But the cool thing that not a lot of
people know in my office,
I have the hat,
the hat with all the feathers and the,
and the what have you.
Yeah.
So when I was filming at his house,
he comes out,
he goes,
hold on a second,
how I get you something.
And he goes in,
comes back out,
and he goes,
I didn't ever know who I was going to
give this to as the fuck.
It's not that one.
It's the one from smoking vent to.
But um,
that is to um,
well fuck it too much.
He is sitting in there and I've got a
picture of him giving it to me.
And um,
I had like man tears.
I mean,
I had like,
my hair was growing on my arms and
stuff,
but,
you know,
standing up and I'm like,
dude,
I can't take that.
And he goes,
oh,
you will.
And I'm like,
okay,
let me just going to tell burt reynolds
know.
And uh,
so sits there
as kind of a memorial and he was a super
cool guy and he was really a car guy
and,
but also there it is.
And he was just giving you his hat and
shit.
Yeah,
he was a bad ass man.
I mean he didn't have a cane at this
point in time.
So whatever it was that he,
he must have some surgery or something
like that.
It was,
I don't think so.
I think it was just frail at the time.
Um,
and he,
yeah,
he was,
this was four years ago maybe.
And now,
um,
you know,
he just passed away.
But uh,
he,
he came around,
you know,
he does the barrett jackson and stuff
wIth us and uh,
I've got a friend of mine that owns
company restorative muscle car that
does,
uh,
just transient type stuff.
And it was cool those smokey and the
bandit years were when I was in
highschool,
81,
I was a freshman in high school.
I was 84,
so I remember watching those,
watching those movies and,
and saying like,
this guy,
he's like having fun,
smiling.
And he was like,
he was silly.
That's the secret to get smoky.
I'm fucking having a blast.
It's not a big fucking deal.
Um,
and,
and did you look at all the other ones
that people don't talk about?
A lot like hooper or stroker ace,
you know,
not to mentIon cannon ball and all the
other ones.
I mean they were literally a group of
guys that kind of took our overhaul.
He would for a small period of time and
just had a blast.
Just had good times.
they were like,
hey,
this might be fun to go film this movie
for two weeks across America and fuck
shit up.
Let's go do It.
All right,
cool.
Well he was just silly.
He was always smiling and silly.
And he had.
Jackie gleason was the enemy.
Like,
come on man.
What do you got?
Jackie gleason is the evil guy,
man,
you got a goddamn great movie.
That's silliness.
I need a dr.
Pepper.
Yeah.
And diablo sandwich and make it a fast.
I'm an ra.
I mean it was just.
I mean,
jackie gleason from the hustler is a bad
guy in a,
a,
a cop movie.
You so bitch.
Those are great.
Fucking sally fields is the girlfriend.
I mean it was just fucking amazing,
man.
You go.
I'd love those movies,
man.
Dude.
And getting to shave and my goatee often
and dress like that and,
and do the show that I did was
absolutely second to none.
I'm like,
this is as cool as it gets.
You know,
I,
I'm done.
Cool.
I do with that car.
Did you sell it?
You have.
We actually gave it away on discovery.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So somebody's got it.
It's a good car.
It was really nice car.
Great looking car man.
God damn those old.
Those trans ams from that year that with
the firebird on the fucking hood.
God there.
So as heavy though,
man.
I mean to.
You can't.
It doesn't matter how good a driver you
are.
That thing is asked heavy.
It'll come around on you in a heartbeat.
Of course.
Mine,
I bought a.
My dad was actually,
they said my
parents told me that I couldn't get it
because they said they couldn't afford
the insurance and everything and they
didn't know I was always hustling and
doing stuff and what have you.
So I just showed up at home one day with
it and they were like,
we told you,
I said I paid cash and I paid for a
year's where the insurance up front.
And they were like,
my dad's like,
where the fuck did you get that money
working?
He goes,
how much money you got?
RIght.
So I take him to a room.
I showed him my shoe box and he's like,
which is more than I make
will we do to make that money?
Oh dude.
I was a hustler back then selling car
stereos out of my truck,
you know,
so anything anybody would buy,
raking leaves,
mowing yards.
I mean,
I was kind of a geeky kid at the time
and a little bit on the small side,
so I had a lot of free time.
I wasn't exactly banging the
cheerleaders or anything,
so I knew I'd just always kind of was a
hustler.
Wanted to make money and how to respect
that.
Oh,
he did.
He did.
He was,
he was actually very impressed.
He was like,
he goes,
we don't have that much in our family
bank account.
Wow.
You know.
And uh,
I was like,
well,
that,
you know,
and uh,
but my dad was a,
it is a phenomenal dude.
Worked three years,
uh,
you talk about a good dad,
you know,
you're a dad.
And so my,
but a good dad.
I mean,
my mom left when I was two,
ditched my dad with me at two and my
sister at six or so and uh,
you know,
it was the seventies.
So you would think that,
uh,
my dad would be like,
I'm going to smoke this weed and drive
away.
But instead he buckled down and got,
got two jobs and worked.
He worked two jobs Pretty much my whole
life and provided for us and we
defInitely didn't have much,
but we had a roof and we had food and
shit.
He's still in contact with your mom now?
Not really.
I hate to say that,
you know,
but mom's,
uh,
she lives down in Florida.
I'm sure she's a whatever she is,
but a little too much for me.
The exact opposite story.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
My mom left my dad when I was five and I
haven't even spoken a word.
My dad went on til from seven years old
on no kid.
Yeah.
Well I've actually,
I've kept up with my mom and we talked
about every two or three years and it
reminds me of why I don't talk to her
anymore.
So then I'm good.
I'm sure if I met my dad would be the
same thing,
but I have a stepdad.
He's a great guy.
I got real lucky.
I had a stepmom and it didn't turn out
super great,
but she did teach me a little bit about
math and you know,
to how to run books because she was
basically a thief.
But so
I at least learned for the explosion one
step mom until I moved out of house
until I was out of high school.
yeah.
then my dad went on to marry like a
series of super,
really fricking just eft up
individually.
He just started running through them and
I was like dad,
married,
any of them come with
two or three of them
about people to get married like five,
six,
seven times.
I,
I respect that.
This is what I respect.
I respect people that keep fucking
swinging,
you know,
even though you go down and the fifth,
you get back up and you go down the six
go down to the seventh there,
you know,
my dad was like that.
He was like,
ah,
it's fucking good party.
So come on out and I'm getting married.
You know,
he had one wife one time.
I get there for like family christmas on
either christmas eve or whatever.
It's like going to the dad's house with
the young kids and what have you.
And we get there and she's all doped up
on,
you know,
whatever pills were popular at the time.
And she's like,
hey,
can I take your shirt off?
Oh
yeah.
When she's crawlinG around on the floor
and try and take off her clothes and the
whole family sitting there like,
what the hell Is this dad?
And so now he's,
uh,
he's in,
an alzheimer's home.
But,
but,
uh,
yeah,
that's the part of what's scary about
turning 50.
But he's like in,
they're nailing all these chicks.
We come,
we go in there and he's like making out
with some girl with a nasal cannula on
and carrying her oxygen bottle.
And he's convinced that they've been
married for a few.
I have a bin in my act about the
outbreak of stds in nursing.
It's out of control.
It's viagara.
Oh,
it's not only just that,
these people,
I mean,
I mean my dad has really advanced
alzheimer's and he knows that he misses
his mustang.
Uh,
I took all those bicycles away and I
need to get laid.
That's it.
And he's in there just running around
with it.
If we got called my sister and I take
care of my data in that manner.
And so we get called to tHe home,
almost like being called to the
principal's office as a,
as a parent.
They're like,
your dad'S literally in here.
Fucking everybody
literally had the feeling of getting
janked in there to the,
to the principal's office.
Like Your kids.
Fuck up your,
your dad's fucking.
But you had to be proud
of what do y'all care?
That's my point.
That's What I say about him in my acts
like,
come on man.
How do you want these people die out?
What?
Their hardest top where they're playing.
Bingo.
Yeah,
have a good time.
Just don't want him hurt each other.
We'll see.
I mean,
I'm in the healthcare business also home
health care.
And so I know,
yeah,
I've got a lot of different ventures.
But what,
what do you in how you in the home
healthcare business,
a home health care with,
uh,
with my wife.
Uh,
we 16,
17 years ago,
maybe longer.
uh,
so in the state of Texas,
it's probably the second or third
largest home health care.
But I'm talking a real home healthcare.
Like you got to get shots,
you've got to get therapy,
you got,
these are trends that are going in and
they're not people you go into bathe
grandma,
what is your business?
You hire a bunch of nurses to take care
of people that are at home.
Yeah,
it's prescribed,
uh,
like through medicare or insurance or
whatever to where maybe somebody gets a
knee or a shoulder replacement or maybe
it's an injury or cancer or what have
you.
And so it's a very rewarding business.
We probably have 3000 to 2,500,
3000 patients at any given time all
around the state of Texas.
And uh,
so it's,
uh,
it's,
it's a fun business to be in that you're
really getting help people.
But at the same time,
that shit out there,
it's crazy.
These guys are,
they're getting after it.
He'd go into the nursing home and it's
like,
damn,
dude,
this 78 year old dudes had more ass than
I had last week.
Yeah.
Why not?
My thought is why not?
Well,
I bought my dad a,
you know,
he's got his room.
That's kind of like an apartment or
whatever.
And I bought him stripper sheets are not
stripper sheets,
but uh,
a twister,
twister sheets with all red and blues
and greens and I hug a board thing up
behind his bed.
I'm like,
dad,
if you're getting after you guys will
have fun.
I mean fuck bingo or freaking whatever.
SO when,
because he has alzheimer's,
does he remember when he gets after it?
I think it said he's just so focused on
and he just,
he was kind of,
what would you call him?
Accustomed nuba.
he was,
he,
my dad got some serious ass my whole
life.
I mean as a teenager I was like god damn
it as like bang and everything.
But when your wife leaves you with kids
when you're young,
you just realize,
okay,
forget about this longterm shit.
Yeah,
let's just enjoy the moment.
Yeah.
But I mean my dad was straight up
products of the sixties and seventies,
you know,
so he,
he like dyed his hair blond and his
eyebrows blonde and shit.
Walk around looking like matthew
mcconaughey.
Dazed and confused.
Alright,
alright.
I'll try driving his mustang.
You know,
can come pick me up from school,
what kind of back then it was like a 72
fast back,
you know,
red and black with a four speed and he'd
be hammering it and I'm like,
you know,
five,
six years old of age,
I'd fall on the floor because nobody
wore a freaking seatbelt back then.
And uh,
his idea of afterschool care was the
skating rink because he knew that thing.
It'd be open till nine,
so drop us off at the skating rink and
ninety nine cent corn dog meal and uh,
he come pick us up usually around 10 or
11 and with some irate skating rink
owners sitting there pissed off and
like,
wow,
he was a bad ass.
It is a bad ass still.
I mean,
he's nailing chicks in a nursing home.
Come on.
It's so weird when You become an adult,
isn't it?
Oh yeah.
You know,
when you think about,
oh,
round four,
we got to drink water from rawlings,
raymond rawlings,
Raymond Miller,
rawlings mother fucker.
That ever lived.
So I looped for sure.
I mean,
I guarantee you he got more acid than
you and I did this all week.
I believe it.
He's freaking probably banging one right
now.
it's like,
hey,
what's that noise in the back?
Sounds like my son is the tv plus the
goal.
the goal is like,
or the bonus rather is that they can't
get pregnant.
You got that mean it's over.
Yeah.
Well that's uh,
that's not happening,
but you can still get some diseases and
stuff.
And they do.
Yes they do.
But the thing is where they getting
them.
Well somebody had it and then the next
thing you know,
all 100 people in that building have
done it right.
But did they have it already or they're
getting it from the building now.
They had it already.
He had already.
So you're dealing with herpes or you're
dealing with the real weird ones like
syphIlis and gonorrhea and shit.
The syphilis and gonorrhea is like,
hey,
you got to treat thIs.
Where are you getting this?
Oh no,
it's,
it's prevalent.
It's everything.
Right.
But the question is,
are they getting it from outside
sources?
Maybe.
I mean,
who knows yet that,
that,
that uh,
unfortunately they just had the baby,
you know,
that it's been invalid for a 20
something years.
That's crazy.
Somebody,
somebody dr.
F and I'm trying to.
Two thousand 11 chlamydia infections
amongst americans.
60 five and over.
Increased by 31 percent and syphilis by
52 percent.
Yeah.
But the problem with that is 52 percent.
All right.
Okay.
Let's say there's 100 cases and then the
next year there's a 150.
Alright.
That's 52 percent.
No big tins of that $100.
Million?
Yeah,
a million thousand.
My dad's probably in their gun.
Come on baby.
I'm going to buy some though.
I don't like the number of percent
because if there's four people and then
the next year there's six.
That's 50 percent increase.
And what I'm saying,
I don't like numbers like that because
you could make.
Oh my god,
it's an epidemic I want,
I want,
I want numbers like human beings.
Yeah.
Well I'm sure it's out there on the web,
but like I said,
my dad's probably thinks committee as a
flower.
He's given me.
He's given this girl,
I'm going to get you some ideas and
we're going to have a good time.
Yeah,
there's no condoms in nursing homes.
You know,
we got 3000 reported case of committee
among people.
40th five and older.
Okay.
But I'm 45 and older.
That's normal.
Forty five and older people are walking
around meeting new people.
Forty 3000.
Seems like a very low number.
Super low.
That's what I'm saying.
That's why I don't like these percentage
numbers gonorrhea had see from doing
this podcast all these years.
I've.
I understand when people can make things
seem greater than they really are.
Go back to that.
Jamie,
do you have your arp card?
No,
but someone set one to us to me and run
to the comedy store,
but I think that was some asshole
thousand.
Sounds low.
Yeah.
Primary and
secondary syphilis.
Five thousand 650 cases were reported in
this age group.
40th five.
The thing about 45 and older is 45 year
old people in 2019.
It's not like 45 year old people in tHe
sixties.
Absolutely.
These animals are out there fucking
hitting the gym and doing squats and
flying to Thailand.
They're probably getting it from the
sweat on the gym bench.
They could get staff.
I know a lady who almost died from staff
from the gym.
She ignored.
She had some weird rash on her leg and
no one told her that it was a staph
infection and she.
She went into shock and had fucking
seizures from staff and she's 36,
37.
She's fucking.
She's my wife's friend.
That's crazy.
Dark shit.
That dark dark staff from a gym.
That's why I don't go to the gym.
That's what I tell everybody.
no staff.
You've got to get it.
you go to go to the gym,
dress like a superhero.
You got work,
tights
going to call myself.
Zero
cards and fucking spray and all the.
All the chemicals everywhere.
Yeah.
Like two guns to spray guns in each hand
of alcoholic.
She everything.
No,
I,
I like the spray gun with alcohol,
but it's one akila and one.
So
do some fucking chin ups.
One of the mouse.
Yeah.
I've got staff twice from jujitsu.
Oh yeah?
Yeah,
ringworm.
Three times.
At least staff twice and they'd be
wearing once.
It's rough ringworms.
okay.
But ringworms basically athlete's foot.
Do you know the same?
More or less?
Yeah.
You know,
you piss on your feet to make athletes
foot go away.
Yes.
Yeah.
Girls go because girls can't aim with
their pis.
No,
I can.
I can help them grow this.
Pat did just coming up with this gas
monkey funnel.
Remember the fundal thing that,
that they came up with the sheet.
No.
Yeah,
there is a thing that girls can use.
They stuff in their crotch that they can
pee standing up.
I just think that's probably not very
sanitary.
Well you're in is not really unsanitary.
It's not really that bad.
It's not a dangerous thing.
Poking golden shoWer.
Maybe they haven't,
but I wouldn't be scared of it.
Not scared to piss.
They'd go.
ms dot rogan.
This is don't pay till he gets home.
This is the thing about a jujitsu.
You're so used to dude's sweating on
you.
Like,
cause you're always looked.
Yeah.
I wouldn't like sweating like there was
one time,
just one time that I was.
I was rolling with a friend of mine and
he got on top of me,
mounted me,
and he was sweating in my fucking face,
like his chest sweat was dripping in my
face and we were laughing about it.
I was like,
dude,
what the fuck?
You're sweating in my mouth.
Basically.
This is starting to get weird.
Well,
it's just part of like learning how to
kill people,
deal with the of training for Texas.
We just use guns.
No,
that's not true.
There's a lot of jujitsu schools in
tech.
I'm looking at the stats on the std
thing for older people,
and this is an article I found said only
five percent of adults are using
medicare to take the std tests,
so it could be way higher if you're just
not getting tested.
It's way high.
They're like,
suck it up.
I was in Vietnam.
Come on.
It's just a rash.
Yeah,
I mean the thing is like who's trying to
stop these people?
Who stopped those people,
they're going to die.
Let them,
let them drop them.
I'd be going in there and passing out
all kinds of lube and toys and get after
it math.
No,
I wouldn't do that.
Why not try it?
If you're going to try matthew,
try when you're 90.
Yeah.
That's an easy way out.
Well,
it's not even a way out.
It's just a way forward.
We gave uh,
these,
uh,
ladies and my family,
weed for the first time when they turn
18 years old.
they've never done anything,
so we give them some brownies.
Wow.
And uh,
we told don't,
don't eat all the brownies at once,
just eat a little bits,
wait an hour or so.
Yeah.
You feel blah blah.
They're like,
well,
we're trying it.
We don't feel anything.
Next thing you know,
it's like only an hour later and they've
made the whole pan.
Now they think it's the greatest thing
since sliced bread.
Like,
just bring brownies,
thanksgiving dinner.
Just bring brownies,
just bring brownies.
and they just like melt with the
universe.
We just tricky in Texas though,
right?
Yeah.
It's not legal yet.
It's going to be.
I'm in California though.
It's right here.
I got that elan musk trouble.
We'd.
What Is that?
This is a,
this is what's called a,
a blunt.
It's a tobacco on the outside and um,
marijuana on the inside and nurtured the
car.
Shit dropped tesla stock six percent one
day.
Oh my,
uh,
my manager and pr person out there.
I just literally shitting their pants
right now.
But it's legal.
Well,
it's legal here,
right?
There you go.
I believe in the law.
It's 100 percent legal.
Here
it is.
A hundred percent.
Who's the dude that I'm.
Oh,
Mike Tyson just brought you some of his
weed.
Is that how it comes?
This is the box of death and life right
here.
Well,
mike tyson's box of death in life.
Yeah.
Look,
this is how hard Mike Tyson roles look
at the sides of these fucking joints he
gave me.
I know the camera's not gonna be able to
follow me,
but I'll be right back.
Ladies and gentlemen,
look at this shit.
Look at the fucking size.
Oh,
that's just insane.
That's you,
bro.
I can't take that.
I can't take it with you on the plane.
How do I get on the plane?
Then you just think thinking you'll
appear in seat four c.
That's the key.
I would recommend any meaning more than
enough for me.
Alright,
jamie,
we'll take one more.
Yeah,
he gave me these joints that would make
you think about people you fingered in
highschool and want to find them on
facebook and apologize.
Just what is that?
That's a goddamn cigar of marijuana.
That's outrageous.
That's tyson has a whole ranch.
He has a hole put in this new one.
He has this uh,
uh,
tyson ranch.
These growing marijuana and he's going
to have like a resort desta destination
or he's going to have like fitness
classes,
like tip toe through the tulips.
Exactly
who this you'll live.
He's um,
he's got a place down in palm beach.
Where was it?
PAlm springs,
palm springs,
palm beach in Florida,
California out in the desert.
They're developing this enormous
property where they're going to grow
weed and they're also going to have this
huge place where people can go and have
this resort,
like a weed amusement park.
Literally,
they're going to have concerts there,
like coachella type events,
what do they call it,
the kush fest or some shit
fucking around the people.
People behind it have deep pockets and
they're going hard because what people
have seen in Colorado and people are
starting to see in Washington state and
now in California,
there's just an enormous amount of money
involved in marijuana,
like crazy,
ridiculous,
silly profit.
If you're doing it and you're taxing it
and you're doing it responsibly.
The way I look at it,
it's no different than going to the
store to buy beer.
It's all combined too much beer and do
something stupid.
We've had four shots in an hour on a
radio show.
I have a driver driver.
That's good.
That's the way to do it responsibly.
That's right.
I mean,
owning,
owning a tequila company in,
in,
uh,
in bars and restaurants.
You kind of have to.
Yeah.
It takes the fun out of it because I'm a
driver.
I'm a car guy.
Everything else.
But yeah,
but be responsible.
Always be responsible.
And the,
you know,
the thing is also
if you are a person who likes fun,
like what are you trying to stop fun?
Like if someone's To smoke a little
weed,
have a little tequila,
drink a couple of beers.
You should.
Is that unless people are being
responsible.
Yeah.
I don't see a drastic difference between
the alcohol or marijuana.
As long as you're obeying the laws being
responsible for paying your taxes.
Yes.
I 100 percent agree.
I also talk about it this way.
Imagine if all the people in the world,
but you,
me and jamie and if jamie had decided
that he.
He thought that we were criminals and
we're not allowed to drink alcohol
anymore.
Jamie's getting installed prohibition in
our small community.
He'll be ridiculous.
We would be like,
fuck you man.
Well that's literally like the
government telling you you can't do
mushrooms.
Are the government telling you you can't
smoke weed?
Like it's just a grown man telling other
grown men they can.
Based on what?
It's not based on what we voted on.
Like if people really knew the
information involved in the safety of
marijuana,
does it freak you out?
Yeah,
of course it does because it makes you
paranoid 100 percent.
But does alcohol make you an asshole?
Fuck yes it does.
Oh Yeah,
but do I think that everybody should
have all of it?
Cbs rejects superbowl that based on the
benefits of medical marijuana.
Well,
In their defense there's probably a
bunch of people or stockholders and
there's a lot of decisions that are made
that are made by lawyers.
I just want it just before people get
angry about something that cbs decided
to do.
You have to understand the cbs is
responsible for the employment of untold
thousands of human beings.
They're going to have bud light ads
right next to this.
They will or whatever they will.
They will,
but bud light,
bud light ads are not going to affect
anyone's bottom line.
I dOn't agree.
I don't agree,
but I just want people to understand
that.
Part of the problem is that the business
aspect of this has not been fully
established.
Once it's fully established,
cbs and all these people are going to
realize it isn't any different than bud
light.
It's not any different than anything you
can get fucked up on bud light if you
just drink 20 of them,
you can get fucked up.
You could walk inTo trees,
you do it on,
you know,
cough medicine or what else?
Oh,
that stuff's out there.
anything.
I mean,
how many pharmaceutical drugs can you
get fucked up on and do we deny that
some people love,
like serious injuries benefit greatly
from pain pills?
No,
they definitely do.
The thing about it at all,
all is you got to be honest and let
people form their own opinions.
and part of being honest about it,
about these things is tell them the pros
and the cons.
Everything has a pro and a con including
whole people banging it out and nursing
home.
Exactly.
Getting committee,
uh,
you know,
that's not good.
The,
the,
the pro and the con is my dad's a pro
banging old ladies in nursing home,
but the con is he's probably got some
stuff on his little winter down there,
probably passing some biological
footballs,
but he's not getting pregnant.
Yeah,
he's not getting pregnant.
No one's getting pregnant and listen
folks,
people get colds.
TheY get the flu.
all sorts of weird things happen when
people corral around are the people.
What are we supposed to live like john
travolta and the boy in the plastic
bubble and fucking lock ourselves in
hermetically sealed chambers and never
touch each other again.
Get the fuck out of this true.
Just take your penicillin back it off,
but that's what napoleon did.
Walk up.
Gladys,
I think you might've given him a thing
or two.
Just hit the massengill.
You'll be good.
I wonder.
I wonder who's delivering these venereal
diseases.
It's like,
that would be fascinating if we found it
was primarily women.
It was like 78 percent of women are the
original source of the venereal disease.
Well,
they pulled the apple down,
right?
I don't believe that happened.
I think there was a bitch ass man who
blamed it on the chick
when I heard that adam and eve story.
I was like,
yeah,
right.
Maybe adam was a bitch.
She blamed it on eve and he wrote,
he was the guy who could write.
So he wrote things down.
He was like either drop a and do shit.
I'm a good listener.
He probably ate the apple first.
I probably gave it to eve.
You know,
history is written by the winners.
This is correct.
And a lot of women just to let that shit
go.
Let them talk.
Yeah.
Right down the night that I will fuck
you.
And he's like,
fuck you.
And adam and eve,
I don't see adam and eve having that New
York accent
where they get it in New York.
Wasn't there yet.
I feel like adam and eve would talk like
british people because anytime they have
a movie where people talk like old
timey,
whether it's gladiator,
whatever.
Everyone talks with an english accent.
Do you ever notice that?
If we have to,
right?
uh,
there's like the suspension of
disbelief.
Like we don't know,
latin and latin,
who the fuck knows?
That sounded like.
Right.
So when,
when you watching some old ass movie
about people talking lot and they'll
speak english,
but they'll speak it with an english
accent.
Right.
That only speak proper.
They always have some weird old timey
movie.
What's ever watched the movie otherwise?
Right.
But you.
But why is that?
Because it's got to make it watchable.
That's why they ruined stories.
What t two english people is that played
out like eleanor's are played out to
him.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Absolutely.
Like to english people,
they hear that accent every day.
That's a normal accent.
But to us it's like,
oh,
this is like an old timey language.
Hangul.
Why is russell crowe talking like he's
from fucking london?
This is bullshit.
Yeah.
I got a friend of mine,
a big chris,
and he likes to say,
well we invented the english language
and I'm like,
yeah,
and he fucked it up.
Yeah,
you guys made it so that people don't
understand it.
That's stupid.
That's not smart.
We've made it better.
We really did.
I just say that my rebuttal to him was
like,
oh yeah,
well somebody from your town still
trying to be a rapper in their defense
though,
they will always say to you like,
yeah,
but listen,
you guys respect our language more than
you respect yours.
And it's true.
Like american english is not as
respectable as english english because
that's why they use those english people
to sell like late night mops and shit.
Right.
Call me dude.
They fucking nonstick frying pans.
It's always some man with a proper
accent.
You look at this,
I can just find these eggs and they
slide right onto the plate.
Believable.
Throw back a nickels in there and
scratch it up.
Nope,
not a scratch.
If that was a guy from jersey that was
selling you that you'd be like,
look at this asshole trying to lie to me
about his bullshit frying pan right.
And his fucking shitty mop.
But something about like english accents
get us foR sure.
They have a better.
They have a more respectable version of
our language,
but our sounds better.
You could say it easier.
I understand it.
They understand us.
We don't always understand them.
That was lIterally just on a phone call
with a,
uh,
a lady in europe before I got in here
and I couldn't understand a word she was
saying.
The thing is though,
here's where I'm wrong,
here's where I'm wrong.
They understand each other.
They fucking,
they'll start.
I was in belfast,
northern Ireland,
which is mind will be in the cantina
scene in star wars.
These motherfuckers,
they barely speak english.
They speak english for sure.
They understand each other a 100
percent.
But to me,
I was talking to this guy and he was
drunk out of his fucking mind.
We were drinking dark beer.
just me and this dude,
this is like early 2003,
early ufc,
ufc in dublin.
I all,
I remember this guy saying how to fight
any man.
He was hammered.
How tiny man,
I'm telling you,
your child and your fucking.
Show them how.
Show them right now.
He says to him,
he was making perfect sense.
All I caught was I'll fight any man.
This motherfucker might've said that a
hundred times and just kept buying
drinks.
Hammered with me.
And some dude from belfast,
we will.
You understood lIke 20 percent of what
each other was saying.
You got to use the translate thing on
your phone.
WoulDn't work.
I'd fight anyone.
Oh,
what is this color?
This guy?
You're saying,
whoa,
you skipped to kill.
This guy is simply going to fight me
to the hospital.
You'd be puttIng off to the side if he
like,
it ain't finished.
But if you're promoting,
pause it.
Now.
Imagine being hammered.
Post ufc event,
trying to mingle with the locals were
drinking dark beer and whiskey.
There's maybe 30 people around me that
are yelling like that and I'm talking to
this dude.
So all the people around me,
who are you drunk?
No one knew.
No one knew what anybody next to him was
saying.
Everybody's loud and hammered and this
guy is fucked up.
And he's telling me this.
How did.
Hi,
my name's john.
And I'm like,
okay,
you go fight him.
That's so funny.
We've.
We've put up this video before that
exact guy video a long time ago.
He.
What is this one was really old.
You talking about this?
Me telling me about this guy
right here,
eight years ago or some shit.
What is that from right at the same time
from an old.
There's two things going on in the
background.
Did you hear it?
Damn,
I had a beard back then.
That's the same guy.
That's hilarious.
Now that's like pikey language,
right?
Yeah.
I guess.
I mean it says you.
The first video I pulled up the study
was from.
I think I typed in belfast or something,
but here's the thIng,
here's where I'm wrong.
They fucking understand each other 100
percent.
They understand every word they say so
wrong.
I just.
I'm just not in that environment.
What do you hang out and you'll get it.
It's got a flavor though.
They have a flavor that we don't have,
right?
It's a dark old world flavor.
Hey listen mate,
that's fucking dude who just came over
on a boat and shooting arrows at people.
They kept that same language
and they're always looking to fIght out
of fucking fight homeready.
Oh,
I'm sure you get a bunch of that shit.
I'm a pretty friendly guy,
so most,
most of that stuff.
I don't get the guys that I get are
people that want to be like professional
fighters and then want to just talk
about it a little bit and they're always
very friendly.
You'd be amazed like people that aspire
to be professional fighters are some of
the nicest fucking human beings you're
ever gonna run across because they've.
They've figured out their own ego
through competition to the point where
they're not really.
They're not.
They're not worried about like putting
out an image.
They know who they are.
Correct,
and they were like real friendly,
like some of the nicest people that have
ever met ever a professional fighters.
That's a weird thing for people to hear,
but I think that for men there's
something about trial through combat and
just just be just being understanding
like what,
what it's like to overcome,
like an insurmountable obstacles for the
average person just makes them calmer.
There's a different kind of human.
The more chill
they are.
My or not my hairdresser for 15 years
been cutting my hair.
He probably don't have this problem I'm
used to.
It was a real struggle.
He's a,
he's a bald head and he's a fighter and
you trust them.
I wouldn't take my and he's a fighter
and he's going to give me a z.
Some muscles is shit like hacking away
with my head.
I'm like,
this is not really trustworthy at all.
Yeah,
there was a video out there.
Someone showed me.
Was it you?
Did you show me jamie?
Some of the,
the,
the uh,
I didn't even ask me what it was for us.
The drunk we are,
um,
someone took a phone,
we had a sound like a hair cutter and
it,
and they run It by people's heads.
I never run away and people freak out on
them.
Oh,
there's nothing wrong with that.
They've run it up the back of a girl's
head.
It's a good practical joke.
I mean,
it'd be way better with a real razor.
So main would be.
But that's a,
that's a big deal for people can be
cutting off their hair.
So yeah,
I've always wanted to shave my head at
least once in life and I never just get
a crew cut.
You're a beautiful man.
Thank you.
Perfect.
Shaved head,
you've got a nice thick head of hair.
Yeah.
No,
but,
uh,
now know contracts with crap.
They tell you what,
whoa,
whoa.
Got to keep the same style man.
Continuity really?
Which I kind of called continuity
because it's like,
do these people really believe I just
did this in an hour or was it over the
course of a few days?
Okay.
Well I'll just tell him.
I'm like,
what do y'all think as,
as,
as producers and networks and whatever,
how,
how bad the I think the american public
is.
I mean,
how unintelligent that You have to do a
scene where I just walked in your door
and sat down here and put on my
headphones and then they flipped me over
somewhere going,
you asshole.
I walked in the door and put on my
headphones.
I mean,
it's so insane and it's like,
it's like the recipe.
It's like you have to tell them
everything you do and then I set up for
the shot and I have to walk out the
door.
They're like,
well,
the audience won't know where you came
from.
it's my fucking shop.
I'm here.
What do you mean
they won't have any idea?
That would be so confused.
It's insane and I've tried so hard to
change the recipe a little bit.
I understand you have to do certain
things,
but why do you have to tell the audience
what they just saw?
Period.
You're noT stupid.
You.
If you make them stupid,
you can make them stupid.
You'd never challenge him ever.
I think that as a society we might be on
our way to that.
What?
What was that show?
Idiotic.
Because I argued all the time.
I love my show and I love what we do,
but I'm like,
why do I got to come out of the door,
put my headphones on and then go.
So I got there and I put my headphones
on.
It was unbelievable,
especially after I came through the
door,
so fucking stupid,
but they've always done it that way and
I think of it at the same way.
I think about cbs and their medical
marijuana ads.
There's like a bunch of people that are
just trying to protect jobs.
They're just like,
we're going to make it easier,
easier for people to know.
You can't have anything left to chance.
The,
the kinda filled her numbers where they
had such a bad thing that they can't
show that commercial,
but at the same time we're selling boxes
that say this will kill you.
Yeah,
exactly.
And people are buying them.
Why do you think they still break up
shows with commercials?
Wouldn't it be more effective if they
didn't do that?
It's just a monetization problem,
I'm sure,
but I think you could get a little more
bang for your buck by having this
episode bias.
So instead of a 100 percent,
not only that,
I think they,
instead of having like two or three ads
every five minutes or whatever they make
it do.
How about you just have a couple of
product placements?
Correct.
Show and have them cost more.
Exactly what you put in the.
Then you got to put it into the recipe.
So some guy like us,
it's car guys that are watching the show
and I'm like,
holy shit.
He just bought that porsche and then it
goes commercial and it's like I'm
getting a beer and I'm going to sit back
down on the couch and in the next five
minutes has been going.
So I went to la and I bought a porsche.
You already wasted that guy's tie.
Exactly.
And the only reason we have to do It,
because you imagine that people are
coming in from these breaks,
it just jumping in the middle of it and
might,
they might be doing that.
How about make them figure it out,
figure it out,
bitch.
Well,
figuring out what they need to get rid
of the nielsen whole bullshit.
I mean,
does that real?
They're still counting cable boxes.
Are they even counting cable boxes and
not doing anything?
You have a nielsen box,
right?
So it's not even like cable box.
There's only like a few thousand or
whatever.
And then they decide what the rating is
and it's like,
are you kidding me?
Because I'll see you in my ratings.
And I'm like,
I know it was more than that on the
energy company,
you know?
So,
uh,
I own a social media company.
I'm like,
oh,
we had way more than
that.
I wonder how they do really know and
whether they just accept the fact that
even if they don't know the real
numbers,
at least they have a reliable percentage
that everyone can agree on.
The problem that everyone agrees on it,
they'll,
they'll set their advertising rates
based on that agreement more or less.
But the real ideology of it is we have
the access because all these devices and
everything else to have the real number,
right?
Like the real,
real number.
But everyone will have to give it up,
right?
Like verizon would have to give it up
and then I'm going to give it to each
other and they want to say,
yeah,
I think they just need to remap the
program and so they can really see how
many people there are.
Because right now in the industry and
people think the viewers are way down
and I actually tend to disagree.
I think they're up just the way that we
count them or bad debt.
It's definitely not good because I've
never been counted fucking filled out a
nielsen thing.
I've never used the nielsen box.
I don't know anybody who has I need to
do.
I,
you know,
I met with.
I met one boy.
You'd once said that his brother was
like,
can you find a picture of the nielsen
box?
Just like you know that directv has some
numbers,
right?
They must have some digitaL.
Hell yeah.
They got numbers down to the way.
Why wouldn't they know?
Even if they're not using it as some
sort of a rating system that affects the
ratings of a television show,
you would think that they would want to
know how effective their product is.
If you can measure that,
why wouldn't you measure that and
they've just never changed it.
They really do need to though.
It'd be way cool if they did.
It would be weird.
Be weird if you find out what everybody
was watching.
What if like keeping up with the
kardashians,
like a billion people in episode.
most of the world is going,
what the fuck?
Yeah,
exactly.
Actually the world is still.
It looks at and goes,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
But what if most of the world,
what if you know what?
What do you think is like the biggest
disparity has gotta be it's gotta be
satellite and cable.
Right?
Because they don't.
They're not aLlowed to measure those.
The mobile phone thing,
like mobile phones or they say netflix
specials,
like comedy specials.
they said 40 something percent of
people.
Plus watch them on their phones.
Yeah,
I mean I've started to watch everything
on my ipad and my phone.
I don't really watch tv anymore.
I watched the ufc on my phone on espn
plus I was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
I'm watching live fights on my phone
with a regular connection.
Not,
not wifi.
This is a weird time.
Yeah.
I remember when we were younger,
we spent thousands of dollars for the
giant tv.
When the box it had the projectors.
Well,
the thing about the phone is this kind
of selfish.
It's like personal,
like if you're watching a movie on your
phone,
it's just you watching that movie.
Yeah.
You're not going to get.
You can't like sit next to your wife and
watch a movie on your phone.
No one's going to deal with that.
Even if you're on a plane,
that would suck.
Exactly.
but watching a fight on the phone is
like,
it's way less interesting than watching
it on the big screen,
but you can take it everywhere,
so eventually they're going to get that
into some large thing like a hologram or
some shit.
That's what I.
Or ar augmented reality.
It's not going to be too much longer
before they're doing all the ai and
augmented reality I think is really
what's.
What's interesting to me.
Wait,
netflix doing something with that right
now with that one show they have out or
you can pick the different endings.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
The
black mirror show.
Yeah.
We go back to that article again.
What was the kind of new articles saying
that.
An example of one I was going to say
like that.
So the tvs are there,
have been known to.
They would screen.
They watch what's on your screen and
send that data back to a database based
off of like everything that's currently
live on tv.
It's the same thing happens with audio
streams and shizam or like there's a
couple of different companies that do
that.
So they sell your data?
Yeah.
Then so that they'll sell that back to
advertisers sort of like the same way.
What's happening with some of these
apps.
That's how that.
That's how people found out that
companies are tracking you because
there's third party companies that are
selling that data once they have it
because they don't,
they don't need it for everything.
See the person with the problem with
this kind of shit with people is that
that's not what the agreement was.
The agreement wasn't that you tell
people that I'm watching the agreement
was I buy a tv from you.
That was the agreement.
Like when You say,
oh,
we're going to sell the data from the
people that are watching your tv,
you're like,
okay,
well yeah,
but the cables that guarantee it's
buried in your cable deal.
Yeah,
the south.
We get to keep it prop south park.
Have a bid oN that,
that whole human setup pad,
they once you,
the terms of service,
like no one's reading it,
but you're agreeing to becoming seen
that episode because could becoming a
fucking thing.
So what,
how's it going?
I'm sorry.
Like just just agreeing to the terms of
service,
like you don't know what you're doing.
And like the joke on that was that your
agreement to become a human centipede.
I never saw a human centipede either
to a couple bars I've seen.
Yeah.
Um,
they're going to get us in weird ways,
but they're just trying to find out
who's watching what.
The thing is like,
should your tv be able to just watch.
You should be able To have a line on
what you're watching.
Because I know people now that just use
netflix and they don't have anything.
They didn't have an internet connection
is hooked up to their television.
Television connects to netflix
automatically.
It's like one of the native apps.
Yeah.
But if you're connected to the internet,
you're getting watched.
You know,
is what most people would say.
I,
I'm so paranoid about it.
I have a little piece of duct tape over
my camera on my ipad.
Good move.
Yeah,
good move.
I don't need that on there,
but the thing is it's like.
Yeah,
but why are you selling data?
Wants to buy it.
Yeah,
but why are you allowed to just collect
data from people?
It's pretty much in the contract you
sign.
I get shit.
Literally there should be two prices.
This should be one where you're allowed
to collect data.
You can collect data for me,
but it costs like 50 bucks more a year.
And the other one where you know,
I,
you can't collect my data,
I have to pay a little bit more money.
That's,
that's kind of happening.
There are apps you can use that'll track
how many,
how much are walking in exchange for
letting them,
letting you turn on that.
They'll give you stuff out,
like whatever.
If it's useful to you.
I don't.
What are you talking about?
Like if you walked by mcdonald's,
they can serve you,
but mcdonald's ad
for sure for sure.
Yeah.
Well that's the ultimate goal,
right?
Is to figure out where you are and
target you with something.
Yeah.
So my friend animal green tree was on
here and we were talking about he lives
in Australia and he lives.
He goes,
he travels like deep into the outback
where it takes us three days to drive in
and I said,
everybody has toyota trucks because
those fucking things never break.
They don't.
And so he gets ads all of a sudden out
of nowhere on his phone.
Every time he goes to a website that
says toyota trucks,
he's like,
what the fuck?
He goes,
I didn't google it.
It was a cook cookies.
Well,
it's kinda called cookies,
but it's not something that came from a
search.
It's something that came from something
in his phone is listening.
We said the word toyota trucks it,
registered it and added it to his queue
of is google.
So many messages.
Were they listening?
So many messages from people that
brought.
We brought this up the other day.
I go to these signs and messages like
you guys mentioned,
do they think it's real estate x?
And they started getting served ads for
that.
Like I said,
I Just said columbia,
I don't know,
penicillin.
he tried to buy stock.
It's like he's got so much chlamydia,
we're going to sell him all the benefits
that it would be smart to.
My assistant just said,
just bought a stock
screener.com.
We actuallY own gas actually
Now
we'll get.
That's a border.
The border wall is a fucking tough
question because it is a certain amount
of people just going to be mad at you.
You fucking cooks which go over there
and soak all those marks can dirks aBout
that.
Some people are going to get,
they're going to get there,
they're going to get angry.
I
might go down and chasing a latina
ladies for sure.
It's a,
you know,
such a hot,
hot topic.
But that's also,
you know,
few open yourself up to comments.
Well somebody brought one up the other
day that was a general discussion
question and it said,
you know,
why don't we just do dna?
Let's say your board,
we take your fingerprints,
we take everything else,
we check you all out.
Why don't we just do the dna and I get
the privacy part of it for later on,
but at the same time you're solving a
lot of problems with the very beginning.
Okay,
this person just came out of here and
they've done nothing.
Right?
So now if they ever do anything we know
to go shoot him in the back of the,
well,
we certainly
could do that,
but we would have to place a gigantic
priority on getting the very best people
in law enforcement.
You would have to eliminate all
shitheads.
You'd have to pay those cops way more
and treat them with the respect that
they deserve as people that literally
are protecting you from violent
criminals.
I was what I know mean I'm a huge
supporter of cops.
I've.
I've been around cops most of my life
because of martial arts.
I know a lot of cops,
and this is a weird issue with people
where they fuck the police.
Know if you're saying fuck the police,
you might as well say,
fuck the humans.
If someone does something bad,
if someone does something bad to
someone,
we don't say,
fuck all humans.
If someone murdered someone,
we say,
fuck that guy,
and then you start breaking it down to
whatever group you're not a part of,
so it's fuck that x generation guy,
fuck that lebanese guy or whatever
nationality he is,
fuck that straight guy.
Or if,
uh,
if he's gay and he killed somebody,
fuck that gay guy.
But it's just humans.
we're all individuals no matter what it
is,
no matter what we're talking about.
And as soon as you start breaking down
into groups like,
oh,
fuck these people,
you can't do that with everybody.
Then just because what's that?
Then it just becomes a fight.
Everybody's touching.
It's,
you can't do that.
You can't do that.
We're all fucking in this thing
together.
Correct.
God damn,
we're drunk,
right?
Probably too drunk or not drunk yet.
You'll have one here that we had all I
needed,
so I'm probably going to be in trouble
for that.
Did they give you a hard time about
that?
Who knows if it's legal in California
where I'm at.
So it's legal.
Exactly.
You know how many people used to go down
to Mexico to watch or whatever or do
whatever.
I'm amazed that people are still
bringing in weed from Mexico.
That shows me have a real lack of
american engine nudity.
That's outrageous.
Well,
the canadians are the ones that are
now [inaudible] dot com currently or
where you redirect you to this spot.
Okay.
Oh,
that is so stupid.
The internet is undefeated.
I gotta give a shout out to my people.
They said that.
That's amazing.
If people did that that quickly.
You got some rocks off automatically
directed to cut screener.
I hope discovery channel doesn't get hit
with a wave of protests.
Which mou on discovery?
Yeah.
It just discovered they have a giant
network though,
right?
Like they have like how many different
channels or on the discovery network
channels I think is like 80 or 90 years.
That's crazy.
It might be more than that.
I mean they have some channels that I've
never even heard of like you know the
brick wall channel or I have idea.
It's just insane stuff.
They divided all down.
I think there needs to be a little
consolidation in the market.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it's everybody loved top gear,
right?
Like top gear is probably like one of
the greatest car shows of all time.
I never really watched it.
How dare you.
I'm telling you,
how dare you.
Richard rawlings,
but it's a.
Is it dead now or is it still there?
The grant.
What is the grand tour or something like
that.
Something like on amazon.
Amazon picked it up.
I haven't watched a single episode of
the new one,
but the old one was shit and part of it
that was fun was that,
you know,
those guys were kind of nuts.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
That's what we do.
You know,
gas monkey.
We cut them loose.
We'd have fun.
We'd light stuff on fire,
break it,
whatever.
yeah.
And there was some violence.
What's the uh,
what's his name?
The head guy?
Uh,
clarkson.
Was it jeremy clarkson got into some
producer,
right?
Oh,
trust me.
Yeah.
I don't know if that producer deserved
it or not.
Had to reserve myself quite a few times.
People get crazy.
You know,
you're putting a show together.
It's
especially,
you know,
those guys,
the producers,
the camera guys,
the sound guys,
the people that are sitting in the
discovery offices and they have jobs.
This is my life I'm putting on every
single day,
you know,
and so not only do I have my whole life
on it and in it,
but then I had to deal with filming it
and I've tried to explain it to them
because they don't care to a point if
the show does well or bad because
there'll be another richard on the road.
But yeah,
there's a lot of high volume approach
when it comes to those kind of like a
cable shows,
you know,
they just try to bang out as many as
they can.
High voLume,
you know,
and they have a formula that they try to
file when they have a lot of like set up
scenarios where people get in trouble
for things where they're not really
getting in trouble.
So it's all set up in advance,
you know,
it's almost scripted,
right?
A lot of reality shows.
Some of them can be.
You just know that just poured the fifth
shot.
How dare you,
or is it fit?
I think it was the fifth,
but um,
I think it's that they,
um,
I was telling myself this morning I
should cut back on drinking.
I tell myself that every morning,
but it's so wild because I've known as
the guy that likes to drink some cold
miller lites and hang out in the garage.
So even,
you know,
my own bars and restaurants and stuff
and they'll come in,
they're like,
I'm buying you a beer.
And I'm like,
sir,
you really don't have to.
I own the place.
Oh,
I'm buying it.
I'm like,
you really don't have to.
They're like,
nope.
Buying it.
Like ringing up sally.
Well,
it makes people feel good.
People like buying people's shit like
that.
That's a beautiful thing about booze.
People like buying people that drink.
Let me buy you a drink.
All right.
It's like a niCe gesture.
ExactlY.
Don't bite people's sandwiches,
right?
They buy people drinks.
Oh,
I'm down for pizza sandwich.
Anything.
Anytime I'm going to buy you an herbal
tea.
No one's
ever said that.
Yeah,
no.
Well,
we're in California,
I'm sure they're saying it right now.
You'd probably say,
would you like macho or just the regular
herbs or like people probably said that
just try to appear spiritual.
I'd like to buy you an herbal tea
juice you with bitcoin and herbal tea.
I had a girl asked me the other day.
She goes,
you're laura seems different.
Interesting,
interesting.
Uh,
I'm like,
I don't get that lady that all.
She goes,
well,
I see you every year here.
Barrett,
jackson,
and you just,
your,
your glow is different clothes
different.
I'm like,
well,
I'm still using the same tom ford axe
body spray thing.
People have weird things.
They say to people to fuck with them.
Or you gaining weight?
Gaining weight.
Richard,
your rs.
Different.
Yeah.
You look so thin.
Are you?
Is your diet okay?
How's your diet?
Okay,
my diet's great.
What's your or has different trying to
figure out what's wrong.
He not happy.
Are you not happy?
Oh,
I'm perfectly abby.
What's wrong?
What's wrong with you?
Fuck it up.
They're hoping.
They're hoping you're ready to crack.
Fucking just juking you.
Come on.
I know you're scared exactly the trick
and you tricky and revealing some shit
here.
Aras off,
richard.
Something's wrong with your aura.
You should probably be able to punch
people that say that we should
definitely go,
hey,
fuck off or as aren't real bitch.
You need to draw the aura.
Show me what to watch.
You get.
You've got to have some science behind
this.
The whole ideology of fuck off is my
thing.
So the gas mcgee ring underneath says,
fuck off.
I'm shaking your hand and
you should always be able to say fuck
off if you can't say fuck off,
but you have to be judicious,
right?
You have to say fuck off when fuck off
is appropriate,
but you have to also salute people when
they're not full of shit.
Yeah,
yeah.
You say you're definitely not the person
I'm telling to fuck off.
You're a.
You're a good dude.
You're all right,
man.
You got to have positive and negative.
Like someone is telling you they're
reading.
They're all your auras.
Okay.
You might be able to.
I mean,
I don't know what the fuck you're
seeing.
I barely know what I'm saying.
I have no idea of what I'm seeing is
really even remotely similar to what
you're seeing.
I'm just assuming.
There you go.
It's just a guess like,
like some people like weird fucking
cars,
right?
Like some people are really into certain
cars.
You go,
I don't get it.
Yeah.
Like a pinto hatchback or something.
Some people are really into.
Those are popular with some groups.
Some people are really into like gross
look and shit.
Yeah.
I don't know what they're seeing.
Maybe they're seeing something different
than me.
Well,
it's probably a combination of their
childhood,
their upbringing,
what have you,
but isn't like.
Is it possible that like personal taste
is a lot like sprinting speed.
Like not everybody is going to be Carl
Lewis,
right?
Not everybody is going to be some who's
another fast guy who's st bull.
Hussein bolt is the fastest ever
supposed to be.
Yeah,
he's the fastest.
However,
not everybody could do that.
So isn't it possible that that would
also apply to taste?
That there's,
there's people out there that really get
what's wrong with your fucking shitty
taste and there's other people out there
that likes fox body.
Mustang.
Fox body I think is the best looking
carval's it's the best ever.
I just left barrett jackson and when you
see something real across the stage and
you're just like,
why in the hell is somebody that I don't
get it and they're over.
They're clapping and they're all happy
ordering drinks for their friends.
Look,
I just bought an 81,
a thunderbird turbo mustang.
Five point.
Oh,
like vanilla ice had in this video.
We're going into dangerous waters there.
Mad my buddy sold when it barrett last
year.
High scar.
It's not the worst car in the world,
but if you had to compare,
what is that like 87,
88.
Like what was that car?
What year was that?
[inaudible] 89.
80 nine
mustang.
Five point maybe it was 87.
He's.
He had to drop top down so his locks can
flow.
Didn't he?
Something like that.
You know,
he grew up just up the street from where
I grew up.
I met him at a ufc,
I believe.
I believe he was very nice.
There it is.
Bam.
My uh,
my friend kevin,
jason had one of those but he didn't
have a convertible rolling in dough.
We were like fucking 20 years old.
That car back in the day was the shit.
If you had one of those cars,
you are a fucking hero.
It was fast.
It was,
it was also like it was a,
the car to have 230 horsepower and it
really,
I know,
I wonder,
it might not have had any more,
but it was good because we were all
stupid and we didn't know how to drive
anyway.
But those cars were that at that time
for whatever reason,
like what,
whatever was wrong with people.
That was a good looking car.
But if you look at that car could pick
like a 69 mach one,
like get the fuck outta here.
How did you do this?
Go to a 69.
Mach one black 1969.
Mach one.
Absolutely best car ever.
It's one of them.
I mean,
there's some arguments out there of one
of the,
but it's in fucking race for sure.
It's in the top three to five black,
69.
Mach one mach piece of shit.
I had a real and it's true.
It's true.
That is rest of my.
But this shape is an order.
That's good.
That's
good.
That is the one down there at the big
picture.
Oh,
is it a 78 year old.
Got to have your headlights on the 16th.
That's right.
This is the missing sidelights.
Seventy one.
Mach one was what?
Keanu reeves had he wished he had a
chevelle.
Didn't he know he had a chevelle after
they stole his fucking mustang?
Dude,
they did the ultimatum.
Okay.
They killed his dog and they stole his
mustang.
Very.
You go,
you got to go kill.
This.
Began to kill some russians.
I actually did some promo for that show
was pretty good.
That fucking movie.
Here's what's there it is.
There's the john wick mustang.
There it is.
The guy was talking to him and rust in
russian about as much.
Fuck,
that's a good car.
This show is great because the kid was
just a total fuck up.
What do I do with this?
Yeah.
Do I kill my kid or kill this dude?
And then he came with what I said we
were talking about your shovel.
You're 68 chevelle.
I go between 68,
69 and those 1970.
Sometimes I look at those 70 zero.
God damn,
that's the perfect car.
They look a little tougher.
IT's a mad man's car.
Look at that one.
Woo.
I need one.
Look at that god damn thing that mock
one.
60 nine.
We're going to build one on the show.
Hopefully this year.
That's a fuck a beautiful car.
Yeah.
Sixty nine.
Mach one.
And the boss for 29 to get Into
buildings over these movie cars because
I've seen some of them up close and
they're their shit.
Go to classic recreation's boss for 29.
Go to this.
You need to see this.
Uh,
he,
he made this murdered out 1969 boss.
And it's.
Look at that day.
How dare you.
Now.
That's perfect.
Christ.
And get that goddamn car ever ruins that
right now.
Give me a call.
I'm like,
holy shit.
That's pretty awesome.
That's about as ameriCa as an eagle
killing a terrorist.
Exactly right.
Look at that fucking car,
man.
Don't go away from that picture.
Jamie.
Go back to that picture.
Good lord.
Might be pretty good.
There's not a better looking car.
There's just different.
Nothing's better looking than that
doesn't exist.
I don't give a fuck what anYbody says.
There's nothing better looking than that
car.
There's just different.
I agree.
We've had a few balls for $29 through
the shot,
but that was not a modern one like that.
There's a rat gang of evil cars from
that day,
but there's not a better looking one.
I mean the,
the,
the manufacturers,
we're just trying to one up each other.
I mean just kind of just the wild west
of automobile and like I'm going to
reach out to you now.
I'll tell you,
and I wish you know,
we're sort of in that again right now.
Yeah.
Right now dodge chevy and a ford are
kind of doing the same thing right now.
They are,
and it's also elevated everybody's
interior game,
which keep that up there.
Don't you take that down.
That's like shutting down porn.
What's wrong with everybody's interior
game stepped up to because it used to be
like the germans.
The japanese had much higher build
quality with the interiors,
but corvette has had to step up.
Its considerably.
The new corvettes are very nice
interior.
Tony hinchcliffe has one standup
comedian,
extraordinary tony hinchcliffe.
He's got a grand sport,
whiCh a lot of people think is the best
of the because it's not too overpowered.
Still got the wide body,
but I look at the interior go.
This is a nice interior men.
It's not like it used to be.
It used to be the car as fast as fuck.
It's put the seat and there's nothing in
it.
You have a two spoke steering wheel that
when you can actually bend it,
you know,
those,
those cars were terrible.
I just noticed her,
these fake clouds in the air.
Yeah.
What they are is these lights that used
to have clear covers.
Instead,
we got this thing from octo lights and
they're a company that makes,
uh,
it's,
it's like a photograph of clouds that
you could see through.
So we put it over the top of the light
itself.
Did octo mom start that until lights?
No.
Gotcha.
Because there's only six lights in here.
Not a well in the old place we had them.
They were stars,
but the news place,
the lights,
these led lights are just not as bright
so we had to change it to clouds,
but it looks at the new roles with the
star.
I've got A wraith,
um,
and it's got the shooting star every
once in awhile.
And really?
Yeah.
So a lot of people don't know that the
star pattern that they put in the
headliner in the car is the exact star
pattern from,
I guess the original factory or
whatever.
Oh wow.
And uh,
it,
uh,
what have you,
but a unbelievable.
You're riding along.
You got stars above you.
It's freaking rad.
Yeah.
My neighbor has one of those.
That car is epic.
It's a two door,
four door knock at the door and get in
it.
And you go with this car is
preposterous.
It's so quiet.
It's like you're barely connected to the
outside world.
There you go.
Those suicide doors.
Look at the fucking ceiling.
Men.
You're barely connected to the world.
Barely.
YOu barely paid attention.
No,
I jump in there.
And uh,
my uh,
poodle fifi jumps in and I got a
standard Black poodle.
This big,
big girl,
if she jumps in there and just like rods
around looking at people.
Did theY develop poodles for some
specific hunting reason?
So they were hunters.
Yeah,
like people think of poodles.
They think of poodles is like a,
like a rich person's to beverly hills
dog.
The ballet.
I poodles
brand as hunters.
And what happened?
A matter of fact,
mine,
uh,
I called her fifi as her name and she
brought a rabbit in.
One nighT she comes to bed,
I'm laying there and I'm like,
what is she messing with?
So I reached down in the dark and pull
up this rabbit.
I'm like,
what the frick and a.
But they soft mouth,
don't they?
They,
they're,
it's in their genes.
They don't kill them.
They bring them to the master as a sign
of respect,
show respect,
plus they don't
kill it.
So she brought a live rabbit into my
who's like a rabbit.
Must've been having a tough day.
Oh dude.
But it went off.
It went all freaking possum on you.
It just laid there and I carried it
down,
put it down to the runaway.
Actually about 10 minutes is what it
took it to come out of frozen state.
I mean it just got eight by poodle and
brought into bed with me.
It probably feels like as long as it's
alive,
just to go with this,
just go limp and hope you're just a toy.
Just hope it happens.
Yeah.
That's the good thing.
She's got her own instagram.
She's doing well.
She's always showing off domestic dogs,
right?
Like they don't need to eat.
They don't need to kill you to eat.
So they're,
they're only,
they're only grabbing you.
So rabbit's probably just keep it
together and he'll eventually get bored.
Exactly.
Has really want to eat you.
What does that to a poodle?
16,
49.
An engraving.
Okay.
How about in 16?
40 nine?
They already fucked dogs up to that
point because all dogs come from wolves.
That's what one of the favorite read
are.
They one of the biggest.
One of the weirdest stories that came
out of a genetics is understanding that
all dogs came from wolves.
They didn't think that.
I think I'm pretty sure they thought
that all dogs.
We're like a combination of a bunch of
different things like wild dogs and
different things that eventually became
like a mass diff or something,
but now they realize no,
every single dog from a chihuahua to a
great dane comes from a wolf.
Yeah,
but I mean there are some dogs that.
What do you do with them?
I meaN you've got 150 pound massive that
just lays there and slobbers.
I had 140 pound master if he lived to be
13 years old.
He was awesome.
He's a greaT dog now.
They're great dogs with this air and
they're smart.
TheY're smart and they're big and I
don't like take.
I don't.
I don't mind.
I mean,
especially here in California,
you got to pick up the dogs crap.
But yeah,
you don't want to pick up a crap that's
bigger than mine.
Texas.
You find dog.
She just shoot it.
Now you got to pick it up.
It's,
it's,
it's everywhere.
There's people walking along and that
just cracks me up.
I'm like,
I'm going to follow this giant animal
around and pick up and shit.
That's the least of your worries.
The real problem is it doesn't
understand how big it is.
and it knocks people downstairs and you
gotta be real careful.
If you have steep stairs and a big dog,
you have to really train that
motherfucker correctly.
You have to let them know,
hey,
you can't jump on the four year old at
the top stair you fucking dummy.
But he's a dog.
He's just loves you.
They love you.
Get a,
you know,
bIg dogs.
Like my friend Johnny Cash was my dog.
He's um,
and uh,
my friend joe sold it to me and he was a
trainer of dogs for movies and shit.
Like,
you know,
the movie,
the incredible hulk with the one with
eric bana when nick nolte,
he plays his dad and nicole is the bad
guy.
And he's like a scientist and he sticks
the hulk serum into these dogs and he
turns these dogs,
these big giant hoking mastiffs.
While the original dog was actually my
friend's dog and he was a trainer of
these dogs and he brought them to fear
failure and on fear factor.
These doctors just laying around like
super chill like that.
That's the cartoon dog.
But there was lIke a real dog before
that.
His name the dog was,
he's a regency massive and his name was
curly.
So anyway,
this guy,
he developed these.
He raised these dogs and made them too.
He bred them to this place where they
just had no aggression,
no aggression to dogs,
no aggression to people like this dog
was like a hulk,
just a giant mass muscle.
But you can come up to it.
Anybody come up to him,
pet it.
Little kids were petting it and he was
like gently kissing their face.
He was the sweetheart of sweethearts.
We run in here and look at one more.
We got more people out there.
I'm good.
But anyway,
he's a big dog.
But he was a super sweetheart.
It's all about like breeders know,
like how they breed them.
Yeah,
for sure.
What kind of dogs do you have?
Just a fifi.
The poodle.
Standard poodle.
How much does fifi way?
Probably 60.
So reasonable shit.
You're cleaning up a reasonable handful.
I know several times a day.
It's like if you have like an english
mastiff.
No,
you got.
You don't have the one bag,
two bags a hunk of shit.
Then you've got to figure out how to
roll this one and roll with this and
got a pot roast of shit that comes ouT
of that animal's asshole every few
hours.
It's insane.
Yeah.
That's a poor.
Fellows and gals don't live very long
though,
unfortunately.
That's what's sad.
Those really big dogs like eight,
nine years.
They're done.
Mine lived to be 13,
which was extraordinary.
That's pretty old,
but he was hurt and I had,
I couldn't walk.
I would have to carry him to his food
and then carry him back outside.
So you can go to the bathroom.
It was bad
trials and tribulations of big dogs.
They're just on the jra.
Uh,
you can tune in on a screener document,
might be one of the greatest things
that's ever happened in the history of
this show.
Is [inaudible] dot com trending yet?
For sure.
and people are going to be mad at us.
Why didn't you have to use a derogatory
term for months?
China?
Well,
I call it a big deck screener.
He's guys are dicks.
They're assholes.
Dixon assholes.
And yet you chose con.
Wait,
we were thinking about manhole,
but it's the same.
But Australia has the proper use of the
word cunt and too much reverence to that
word in America.
people get confused about it.
And Australia,
they just throw that bitch around like
it's a beach ball concert.
I've some australians on mY show.
Yeah.
It's like even,
you know,
I'm from Texas.
I'm like,
holy shit.
He's saying that we're a lot of these
fucking cunt.
He's a good can't.
That's my favorite.
He's a good cat.
And they made that like,
you might as well Be replacing the word
cunt for dude because it's all about
intent to them.
It's basically saying,
hey,
he's a good dude.
He's a good dude and there's not as good
con.
There you go.
It's not bad.
Got to have a set of these.
That steel though.
This is a plastic sell.
Their company that,
uh,
is uh,
they make these one off little dolls and
then you,
it the.
Oh,
these are hand painted little kid.
Yeah.
This guy's a beast,
man.
A plastic sell on instagram.
He makes all the stuff that's pretty
rad.
No,
he's,
he's wicked.
He made one for my dog.
Oh,
he did?
John wick and his dog.
that's from john wick dose.
Not john brick.
Uno function.
I'm twisted.
Can I have to couch surf from john wick
one?
I'm wrong.
Moves from john wick one that he had the
pit bull.
Yeah,
it was.
Yeah.
John wick two.
They killed the beagle and then he had
the pit bull and they started going and
killing spree.
It doesn't have it three out now.
They're another one working on it.
It's coming out soon.
Yeah,
he's a cool cat.
I ran into him at a deus ex machina down
in santa monica,
venice area.
And he was on one of his bikes and super
cool,
rad dude,
just,
hey,
what's up?
And keanu reeves must be one of the
nicest,
coolest people in the planet because no
one has a bad word to say about that guy
ever.
He might.
He might be what we should all surprised
or be.
We should all aspire to be keaNu reeves
who you might have sOme really crazy
secrets that he's the nicest.
It seems like everybody runs into him,
you know,
like,
I'm sure there's some people that ran
into you or they call you the wrong way
and they're all went sideways for a
little bit.
Nah,
not really.
I mean,
but no fucking keanu reeves got it going
on.
But the point,
what I was going to get to is one of the
things that those movies did was they,
they elevated the profile of those
muscle cars because people saw that
movie and they went this guy for.
There's something about him.
I know he's murdering people.
I know he's the best at murdering
people.
I know he killed three guys in a bar
with a pencil.
I know that.
But look how fucking cool he looks.
He's got.
He's got the dopest suits.
He's killing people.
He's not killing people in an under
armour rash guard.
Okay?
He's killing people in the dopest suits.
He stabbing people in the neck and he's
driving a seventY chevelle ss.
But the trick is unlocks your fore
mentioned in loved eleanor.
It wasn't plasticized.
It was a real fricken muscle car.
Didn't have shit hanging all over it.
And extra side pipes.
YOu're right,
you're right.
But you're also wrong because eleanor,
look at that.
God dammit,
I'm going to kill somebody.
I'm doing it just like that.
God,
come on,
it gets
out of his shoe.
He's got craters on it.
Chevelle.
Ss from 1970 with krieger's.
It's torque for us.
Look at our control or this.
Yeah,
look how good he looks with that craig
or style,
um,
that.
That's a classic white wall tire.
I mean,
come on man.
Or white letter tire.
Raised white letters.
Come on.
That's class.
Or you can get your own.
Now you can get your name on it.
You could do anything because of gas.
There's a time that sells these
stickers,
monkey tires.
I should,
but you can actually order stickers now
that,
that are the rubber letters that fused
themselves into the rubber on your tire.
So you end up with a white letter like
that and you put anything on there.
Wow.
Like joe roGan or you know,
constantly.
Pretty
sure someone's going to send you and me
photos of their car.
A 1970 chevelle rolling around with
screener.com.
Another company that does.
It's going to send a sets for our car.
I don't think.
I don't think they'll let you in the
golf course that she had after the
burrito incident.
I guarantee you they'll make it on small
little golf cart tires.
I need a set of tires for 10 inch wheel.
Need a smaller font?
Please try to fix this electric golf
cart.
That's all.
I'Ve got a golf cart.
I dragged my neighborhood.
That's insane.
It's a polaris like four cedar with the
little truck bed.
and uh,
I drive it all around the neighborhood
because I got a nice little neighborhood
and get to the grocery store.
I get to get something to eat,
could go to the bar or whatever.
And uh,
so I raised total hell with this thing.
I dropped through people's yards,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a great neighbor because I'm really
fun and if I do accidentally fuck
something up,
I will definitely pay for it.
But at the same time they're like,
okay,
does it have to have 32,000 speakers on
it?
And a 50 inch television screen.
A white wall.
Tires don't exist.
What happened to white wall tires?
But the only exists on classic cars.
Oh yeah.
You're not going to see him or anything
new,
but the lettered tires are starting to
get more popular with brand new ones.
But the white wall now remember the four
or five inch white wall.
All right.
I'm going to tell you,
I'm going to talk to you about a
polarizing issue.
Yeah.
Ready?
Raw.
Well,
porsches,
I have no idea what you're talking
about.
I'm talking about.
Nope.
those wide body weird japanese style
body kits they put on old porsches,
liberty walk shit or giant white ass
bodies are a.
You got it.
I don't know anything about here is r a
u h w e l t.
How the fuck do you not know about this?
Can afford collecting porsches,
but none of these are old cars.
These are not the most expensive cars.
The one that's an old accordion bumper
that's been smoothed out.
And so it's like 78,
79.
But you see the bolt on bumpers or the.
Excuse me,
the bolt on fender flares.
I like that we in the front.
Yeah.
Well this gentleman out of Japan
and he does all of these raw welt cars
by hand and uh,
go to him.
What is the guy's name?
So I could uh,
give the guy that his props.
But that dude right there with the.
I love r w t shirt on.
He's a,
his name is kierra and the chi and he
all raw.
Well cars he does himself.
So he'll fly out from Japan.
He saw cells,
you're fucking fenders off.
Puts these flares on the front and the
rear.
There's some amazing videos of him
because he's a real character.
He's chain smoking cigarettes the entire
time and he's like measuring the shit.
He does it all by hand.
He lays the caulking around the edge by
weather sealing.
That's the guy right there.
I'm going out on a limb,
then I'm going to invite him to come to
Texas and do my rave.
I will in porsche.
Well,
I've been considering doing a wide body
on my race just for the hell of it.
And I would let him go do it if he would
be interested in it.
That would be amazing episode.
But if you wanted to just do what he
does and,
and,
and you know,
get a porsche,
like that's kind of his style,
but he takes these things and makes them
fucking cartoonish wide.
Well fuck.
That just cracks me up.
You're dealing with like 20 inch tires.
That's fricken super close.
They're outstanding.
My deal with gas monkey,
like you say,
okay,
well I could actually tell you,
yeah,
we can do that,
but I'm like,
this guy's known for bringing us as in
let's have some fun.
Let's watch his talent.
I gotta I gotta I gotta situation there.
That's what rutledge from top gear,
you know,
rutledge would,
uh,
I know the name,
he's a nice guy,
super nice guy.
He's been on this podcast before.
He's doing one of those cars and he's
doing it with a,
an ls swap.
So instead of using an air cooled
engine,
we already did it.
Oh,
you already did that.
It's a good move.
Why is it so prohibitive?
Oh,
I don't know.
It's a porsche people,
you know,
the scientists,
the seinfelds of the worlds and god
bless you side.
They're like,
ah,
it's not original purists.
We did a nine slash nine slash 2000 2001
convertible and did the ls swap.
And we finished that in 2000 late 2016.
And I had a brand new 2017,
nine slash 11 turbo s,
uh,
in the signal green.
And if I didn't mess with the buttons,
if I didn't turn off all the stuff,
I could not get away from that car till
about 140 miles an hour.
I couldn't get away.
Look at this thing.
This is it.
Look at that.
Who is lord?
We went freaking.
Oh,
you changed the headlights to so nine,
nine,
six.
He went with a nine,
nine,
seven headlines.
That car was so frigging
with nine slash 11 gt three.
The front where the bumper is.
Open vents.
Oh my goodness.
Car was fricking great.
Dairy really tear it up.
That's beautiful.
Where is it?
A friend of mine owns it.
I told him,
I said,
you can buy the car,
but if you ever sell it,
you've got to ask me first.
He would fuck him.
I know,
right?
Fuck him,
tony.
Tony,
you suck.
You have that car.
The thing about those,
it's so weird that you're not allowed to
do that,
but.
But hell,
that was three years ago,
man.
Oh my goodness.
There's not again.
All right.
Put that right next to the mustang.
Mach one.
It's not better.
It's just different.
Yeah,
there's whole fucking credible.
They both have the same reaction like
that car,
which is a 2001.
That was like a zero or a one.
Yeah.
Was that car?
The way it's modified,
the way it's put together,
it is so fucking pretty.
If you had that next in that 69 mach
one,
they're just a different taste.
It's a different feel,
but that's a fucking amazing car and
maybe in the future you might look at
that one even better when you consider
the performance.
That's my other car.
A tuner.
We built the down there,
the two 80.
See the green one.
I always wanted to 40,
but that's a to 80 with 13,000 original
miles and we went nuts with that.
And did the whole a lexus swap as 22
jays,
whatever.
Let her tires.
Oh yeah.
Bringing them back at car was cool.
I sold it to a customer,
no bullshit for a pretty amazing amount
of money for a to a to z and it was
being shipped and the truck burn to the
fucking ground.
Yeah.
What happened?
Who knows?
But the whole trailer burn to the
ground.
Well,
you know how there's been these fires
out here in the northeast,
but still do you know about California
has had some pretty crazy fires.
There's a guy up the street that are
really nice.
Three series bmw burned to the ground.
It's still sitting there.
I took pictures of it.
I put it on my instagram out.
You need to tell him to call me.
Here's what I think we do because there
have been some really amazing cars that
have burned with the fires that happened
this past year.
The panels are still good though,
right?
Don't worry about the panels.
We take them.
I need to make you this in here.
This conference table.
You take it and that's it.
So you take the real special car that
burned down.
You blow everything out,
you clear coated so it doesn't stink and
what have you.
We put a glass top on it and you have a
conference table called burning up the
competition who are whatever,
but I think I think some of those really
expensive burned out cars would make
really cool.
Conference tables.
Yeah.
Good art projects.
Yeah,
for sure.
Background.
You got lucky bitch.
Just having a big plaque.
You weren't in the wrong place.
The wrong time.
Yeah,
I.
I'm a big fan of those.
E 46 m three's those 2000 ish.
I do not know him.
I don't know,
can I be a w dot?
There you go.
Good.
I'm in american hot.
Rodder customs silver.
He forTy six m.
he was saying so many numbers.
I was worried you were baiting me to see
if I'd like that.
Yeah,
those are cool.
There was no 40 6:00 PM.
Three 46.
It's a super well balanced.
Fifty slash 50 balance car from like
2002,
three and many people think it's like
the gold standard for [inaudible]
because [inaudible] there's something
that happened at [inaudible] and right
now I liked the fact that it [inaudible]
became an m for like stay right there.
Don't move [inaudible] muscular car.
That's a fucking good looking car
because the [inaudible] is a totallY
different thing than an m three.
It's beautiful and it's amazinG.
Like an [inaudible] from bmw is a,
an amazing driver.
like if you want to drive that car every
day,
you'll be super pleased.
That performance is unprecedented in the
edm world and most of the car world,
the only things that are faster like
fucking gtrs and corvettes that are zr
one zero,
zero six as a shit.
But it's different because in m three
was really light,
it was really light and uncomplicated.
There wasn't any traction control or if
there was,
it was minimal.
Mostly it was just antilock brakes and
it was a,
you know,
3000 pound car and it had 333 horsepower
and is perfectly balanced for the right
amount of thrust,
the right amount of grip with the tires
because they weren't the widest tires,
but they were wide enough.
they a little bit of fender flare that
made them wider than a standard three
series.
And it's just a perfect understated
looking car.
When you look at that [inaudible] 46 and
three,
you look at that car like that sudden
that's a fucking good neutral zone.
LIke they nailed it.
Cool.
If anybody has one of those I'm buying,
you can reach me to cast mucky duck,
sell it,
sold it,
right?
Well what we do is we buy like 10 or 20
of them and then we sell one at auction
for like 15 times what they normally
bring them.
Then we sell the rest of them.
But look at that car.
That's pretty damn good.
It's good car
you want,
but there's a balance.
That car.
It's not like a ferrari for 88 or some
shit like that where it's so outrageous.
Everybody goes,
everybody gets light.
no,
see you got me there because I don't
like rear engines.
Oh,
you don't?
Not in the ferrari tyPe stuff because to
me know if you get a friend engine b12
you're a sore.
Look at that.
If you've got one behind you.
Oh,
you just got a contract of some sort and
you might not have that car next week.
Look at that car.
Alright.
Do you own one?
No,
I think I need to.
Cool.
I need to eat 46 m three in my life.
Look at that.
That's a.
It might be.
It's perfectly understated and yet
flashy.
It's like a balance.
So what's the value on that right now?
Because I'm serious.
I don't watch that kind of car.
They're not crazy.
They're not crazy becauSe I think people
overlook them.
They overlook them for more extravagant,
like [inaudible],
which is the v eight years.
So if you go buy one,
what would you pay for one right now?
Let me just a nice California wine.
No rust.
I have brain damage so I've critical
thinking,
see,
know off.
I'd have to call my buddy dennis on
something like that because I just don't
know.
Those kinds of cars.
There's something about that car that's
very appealing because it's a balance
issue.
It's not like there's something about
the mach one that's like,
holy shit,
you know,
like America.
Fuck yeah.
So here's what,
here's what we do.
We,
we put it out to the people listening.
Bring us a nice one owner,
low mile in three that it hasn't been
dragged out.
Six 46,
46 m three that it hasn't been dragged
out and I'll bid against you and we'll
see who gets it.
I had to m three's in a row at least two
and three's in a row from bmw for the v
eight years because it was so good.
It was my daily driver.
It was so good.
After I would get out of it,
I was like,
this car is everything.
I like.
It's understated and yet it's wicked,
it's got veto power,
but yet it's not preposterous.
Like the wheels don't break loose every
time you hit the gas it has a double
clutch transmission,
so it's good and traffic and it also has
a whale because it's got this high
revving va and in so many things that I
liked.
I got them in a row so they're going to
send this one on the inter webs and then
we'll send the shit.
I got a pretty good reach.
I think I can get ahold of bmw.
No,
I couldn't get ahold of the people that
own one in their garage right now that
are probably a at the golf club.
So we'll just bid against each other.
So you'll get to.
Because I don't know what will happen.
I'll let you get it by a different one.
I'm not that stupid pro.
How about we do this?
Let's buy two of them and race.
Um,
I'm not good at racing.
Straight line.
I don't care who gets there first.
I just like driving and no bullshit,
no bullshit from your wife.
But for real,
I don't.
I like watching racing,
but I really don't care if you get there
first.
All I care is about going sideways and
correcting and hitting the target proper
apex and stomping on the gas and knowing
when to brake and knowing when to like
dig in.
If you get ahead of me,
I don't give a fuck.
I really don't.
I'm just trying to have fun because I'm
not a professional racer.
NeIther of if that's all I wanted to do.
If I was danica patrick,
then that's what I'd be into.
But I'm not and I,
I don't.
I really just like driving cars.
Yeah,
me too.
I'm not a racer at all.
If you and I drove,
I would let you win because I'd like
you.
Oh
yeah.
I'd let you win because I like you.
So we're just going to be sitting at the
starting line.
Look at that.
Two thousand,
140 6:00 PM.
Three
25.
I don't want to convertible.
Yeah,
I think that uh,
if you're going to drive it,
drive a car,
then you don't want to start with I have
one convertible.
I have a 1965.
It will find that hey,
let's find one on there and I'll buy it
right now.
I called the guy
I know.
Go sell them one of those.
Well you got 100 $8,500.
We'll get that 46,
six speed.
Low miles.
$13,000.
You can't even buy a 69 mach one for
anywhere near that.
Not even near that.
That's a good car too.
I would love that.
Caused some stereo.
He keeps it covered.
I'm a fan.
I just think that there's some years
palace.
Virtus.
Super close.
Okay.
If he can be here in the next uh,
20 minutes before we get it done or
however you want that close.
It's basically a long beach.
It's like an hour and a half.
Long term here is like four hours.
Three?
Yeah.
Three pm.
It's four hours.
Yeah.
It was sad that.
What do they got?
long beach.
Nothing.
His last queen,
the queen.
A queen elizabeth.
Whatever.
The queen mary.
the queen mary.
Yeah.
There's a laugh factory down there in
long beach.
There's a lot of things.
A lumpy cfo always wanted to try comedy.
Really?
I,
um,
I just want to try it tonight.
No,
I'm not exactly prepared.
I can make it happen.
I just don't know how.
I mean,
I,
I know that it's a,
I mean,
it's a very rigid process and you have
to really refine.
And I've looked at it,
I've studied it and I'm like,
I think I could probably a funny dude.
I think you could do it 100 percent.
No bullshit.
You 100 percent.
Could be a comedian.
I needed to go to comedian school does.
Doesn't exist.
Oh really?
Yeah.
This is what you gotta do you gotta make
friends with professional comedians?
Will be honest with you.
Like this is like what?
One of the beautiful things about comedy
is that it's very much a,
a brothership and a sister for sure.
I've seen it.
Yeah.
There's a brotherhood and sisterhood
that exists with comedies where there's
no institutions.
Even though it's like one of the
favorite things of people.
People love to laugh.
It's one of the rare things that gives
you a very specific reaction.
Like if you go to see a movie and it's
like a rock movie like jumanji or
something.
It's fun.
Sometimes it's funny.
Sometimes it's exciting,
but it's a bunch of shit going on.
You go to a c stand up,
you got to see Kevin Hart standup you.
You're going there because Kevin Hart is
drug dealer.
Okay.
That drug is laughter.
He's here to hit you with some fucking
high level gigantic arena laughter.
And you get to walk out of there going,
holy shit.
That was fun.
Yeah.
Woo.
Like he gave you some drugs.
Ah,
no.
I,
I think I might try one day.
You can do an open mic.
Go out there and go.
Hey,
I'm,
I'm richard from a screener.com.
You can do it.
There's a lot of places.
Addison improv.
Good spot.
Yeah.
Addison improv is great.
It's a great spot.
Not only that,
not only is that great,
right next door is the cobi steakhouse.
Yes.
And you can get out of the chop shop and
if you get hammered you can go to that
piano bars.
That piano bars till their piano bar is
still there,
but I'm the right next to coby is the,
uh,
memphis.
Uh,
it'S a lounge memphis lounge and that's
always a time I have met a few of my
wives there.
I've worked at many times.
That's a fun place to work.
I used to love to do that circuit.
What I would do is cap city in austin
and I would do the improv.
Well when did the.
There is an improv and addison,
but there's another improv to write
that.
I haven't done that in fort worth.
I think so.
I think there's one like 40 minutes
away.
Yeah,
it's like fort worth.
And then there was a laugh stop in
houston and that was the run.
We'll see.
Dallas,
you need to,
you need to do gas monkey live.
I hold about 2007 people.
And what is it?
You have a concert place?
Yeah,
I've had motley crue there.
Dude.
I graduated high school in [inaudible]
87 and somebody had told me two things.
One,
you're going to build a car.
That hot wheels is going to make and to
you're going to a motley crew at your
bar.
I'm like,
no way.
That's incredible.
So is this the place that you were
building on your show?
Yeah.
You have a 2000 seat place there?
Yeah,
I think we're 22 now.
What's,
what's really bitching about this is uh,
the,
the stage is solid concrete.
It's not raised.
So the reverb and the and the sound that
we get out of there.
Even the guys from crew when they played
it was a deal with dodge and me and them
and bob,
they were supposed to come in and play
like 41 minutes or something and they
played for like an hour and a half and
we're like,
we hadn't played anything like this in
decades.
And the sound is fucking insane.
That is so cool.
Dude.
You're like an uber businessman.
He just dip your toes in everything.
I call myself an entrepreneur because I
always put my hands into shit shit.
So yeah,
I didn't run across the street.
You got a restaurant bar.
You're making music.
Music venues?
Yeah.
I were doing an energy drink,
gas monkey energy
in it.
We're in every 7:11 in the us with the
gas monkey energy.
It's not energy drink.
It's powered with all kinds of b
vitamins and we where our sugar,
we use real honey.
Better deal all the way around.
Wow.
You get it from slave bees?
Uh,
yeah.
Well I didn't know if there was any
other crack the whip box b.
I had a bit about that,
about how you're a vegan.
One of the most crazy things about being
a vegan.
It's you can't eat honey.
Did you?
Probably the oldest substance for
nutrition in the world.
It's one of them.
It's definitely the top million,
but that these bees are not like your
slaves.
You can't just force them to make honey.
Yeah.
You can stick them in the box.
They don't care.
They don't.
They don't even know what's going on.
Do you think there's any honeybee
trafficking going on?
Yes,
for sure.
And it's awful.
it needs to stop and it's mostly by
white people.
I was living in la the other day and
this lady had like 24 eggs and they were
scanning on a.
Well,
you never know someone's.
They make fake eggs.
They do and you could put drugs in that
fake egg.
No bullshit.
Yeah.
It really is.
Look,
if you're a drug dealer and you're
making millions of dollars off cocaine
and ag of coke,
imagine how fucking how valuable an egg
filled with coke would be there.
Yeah,
like a rocker coke.
That big.
Take a guest jamie.
how about like an ostrich egg filled
with coke austrian tank full of coke?
Yeah,
a good goose egg.
I haven't done anything like that and
says,
oh,
they're really,
really small job.
Ostrich egg filled with coke.
Google that.
Don't be scared.
It probably comes up.
That's the problem with google is like
you're sitting there thinking with your
buddy or shoot the shit and you're like,
oh,
I just thought of something really cool
and googling like,
nah,
fuck.
It's probably someone getting arrested
for having an up their ass.
Did you see that cia spy kit where they
had to stick it up their ass?
Fugitive.
Ostrich farm fraudster martin.
Every extra dime.
Is that kind of an ostrich egg up his
ass?
Is that what you're doing?
And this berg,
he was doing drug dealing with ostriches
oh,
how did he get the drugs in the ostrich?
Uh,
uh,
it would be beak,
not nostrils.
Well,
they have nationals.
Can weird man.
I knew a guy,
you know,
you haven't done a lot of the world
rallies and I'm the gumball.
$3,000 of the bull runs and all this.
So one guy appeared on the scene for a
few years and it was kind of weird.
He was there but he wasn't there and he
was kinda not really competing,
but he had all these expensive cars.
It turns out that that's all he'd been
doing for four or five years,
was shipping these cars from town to
town,
uh,
on regular shipping trucks full of drugs
because who's going to search a
lamborghini?
Mercy lacoe.
Right.
Would just assume he's there for the
gumball rally.
Meanwhile,
he's a dope dealer.
Exactly.
Now that guy,
I think he's in the jail now.
One of the things about cars,
right?
It's like cars.
They,
they,
uh,
men's baser instincts respond to cars.
You know,
it's something about like,
like a lamborghini,
like,
ah,
there's something about those cars.
It's like you want to kind of slightly
slightly escape from society's
constraints.
Oh yeah.
But I'm not a,
I'm not a fan with the,
those cars.
I do it with the old cars.
Yeah,
like the old shit.
I mean I have some new stuff.
Don't get me wrong logos either.
It's just something about,
well there's some weird so wide and big
and crazy and it's so can't get in and
out.
I mean,
it's so rich too.
Every now and then on sunset,
front of the comedy story seeking these
guys was
flying by the comedy store and the cars
are like five fucking miles wide.
Each cars,
they're super wide.
Yeah.
And you always know
the asshole that doesn't know what he's
doing because he's pushing in the
collection.
There's no catch.
There's no clue.
Well,
not anymore.
He's putting this neutral and doing it
literally doesn't exist.
These guys that drive around and they're
like,
you know,
look at me now.
I'm like,
dude,
just travel car.
You don't ever get the satisfaction and
washed them stall out anymore though.
Like someone who doesn't know how to do
this is true.
I sold out my bronco and I was everybody
around me that was looking at this car
that got jealous.
That's for you feel better about
yourself.
I'll fucking stalled out to lose.
Ah fuck.
Everybody had to wait an extra 30
seconds and they're all like,
you fucking loser.
Nah,
pretty bad ass bronco.
It's about as bronco,
but you ever been to los anica boulevard
right?
When it hits sunset,
that's a steep ass.
Hell,
bro.
You got to come around to dudes with
manual stall out on that motherfucker.
Yeah,
we started the gumball 3000 there one
time.
Oh really?
We started on that hill.
You had to clear that light just to go.
That's a good move to these screwed up
all the top.
That's a good move.
They should've never mowed down the
blues though while they voted down.
Here's the thing,
I agree with you 100 percent,
but yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm not scared.
Round number.
What is this?
The thing about the house of blues,
that was bad ass though when it went
away.
So I live with my friend.
Yes sir.
A new friend.
So you're going to teach me comedy.
[inaudible] 100 percent help you out.
Um,
when it was down,
when they tore it down from the comedy
store,
you could see across and you see all the
beautiful lights,
like the lights in the hollywood hills.
I had a buddy of mine bought a house in
a off a doe heaney,
which is like way above the hill.
You'd go to his backyard.
He would look out the lights.
You'd be like,
this doesn't even seem real.
It's like blade runner,
like most people see the lights when
you're down in them.
But when you're above hollywood career,
looking down,
it's one of the most spectacular views
in all of history.
It's way better than any New York city
view because you have a view on top.
Look at that.
That's what you see.
And I'm telling you,
man,
this is dog shit compared to my friend
larry's house.
You'd look out there,
you look at that and you go,
holy shit.
That's incredible.
It was mesmerizing.
The image was stunning.
That's pretty good.
A couple people that have houses up
there.
I know dane cook's got a crazy house up
Like a lot of guys have houses up there
that looked down like I've always wanted
to meet him.
He's a rad dude.
Yeah,
he's at the comedy store all the time.
Well he's.
What was that show?
He did my best friend's girl or
whatever.
I think it was a movie.
Yeah.
Movie that is probably one of the
veterans that was out there.
It's pretty fucking hilarious.
What's your all time favorite movie if
you had a.
If there was one,
one move.
Smokey the bandit.
God damn.
Every time.
And,
and if I had to get an in depth
and think about it,
I might go with stroker ace where the
giant uh thing,
uh,
the smoke tower failed.
He goes right under it because these
guys were doing their own stunts.
That shit was real.
That when cgi and they were doing it.
What was that one movie with the girl?
Her name was domino.
Uh,
he was a detective called domino.
Was it called domino?
I don't remember who.
Was that?
What it's called?
Are we talking about with burt reynolds?
Yeah.
You know like the,
what's it called?
Domino during cannibal run.
When they drove the car into the pool.
Oh yeah,
like the nascar looking thing.
Yeah.
They did that because they were fucking
drunk.
They were loaded and they were partying
and the camera's just having to be
rolling that.
And that wasn't planned.
It wasn't part of the script.
They did it because they thought it was
funny.
What is it called?
Sharkey's machine.
That's right.
God damn what years?
That 81.
I was 14 years old.
I remember watching this movie on tv.
I was like,
god damn,
I wish I was burt reynolds
and the woman who was his girlfriend.
Oh my god.
She was so hot.
Look at her
leg warmer days.
That's when they.
Yeah,
they had a leg warmers back then.
No one had a.
Nasa didn't even figure out
when they figured out assets,
sir.
Mix a lot,
ladies and gentlemen,
why people were in the days.
We didn't even know what to ask was sir.
Mix a lot.
Came along and changed the game.
He came along with baby,
got back and we were like,
wait,
wait.
Oh my god,
that is better.
It was like everybody just got smelling
salts under their nose and then the
kardashians fucked it up for all this.
Everybody woke up,
I think did,
but they didn't.
They exploited a hole in the system.
You know like Jennifer Lopez had strong
ass game way before them,
but it was a legit latina asking.
Correct from years of dancing and
fucking running upstairs and shit.
Right?
Correct.
Whatever the fuck she did.
Well also she's like four foot two
machine.
It's just pretty short.
She's probably five foot one or
something and she was pretty short pack
it all in small area.
He got to get it in.
But those movies,
man,
like burt reynolds movies for whatever,
deliverance doesn't get the respect it
deserves.
That is one of the all time greatest
drama movies of all time.
I actually have a picture when I was
filming with burton's house,
a similar in my phone.
I'll never find it.
Uh,
but um,
I was in his memorabilia room which also
doubled as a weight room and just there
was stuff everywhere and I was texting
away,
I was dealing with a problem and
somebody snapped a picture of it and the
deliverance,
a canoe is laying up against the wall
and there's all these different
memorabilia things in there.
And when I say memorabilia like that,
it was like a hoarding room.
There was just.
Everything was in there and it was
unbelievable.
It's like the most surreal thing because
I'm hammering away and there's like
everything behind you do that.
Did you.
Here's the other thing about that movie.
And by the way,
burt reynolds,
university of Florida played football
was a fucking
dud.
Yeah.
That movie introduced me to the world of
compound bows.
I didn't even know what a compound bow
was until I saw that movie.
I don't know what a combo is now for
bowhunting pro pro man
bell.
Ronald burt reynolds reynolds.
I was taking a bow.
Hey,
uh,
jackson needs you to Barbara Reynolds.
Dr. Jackson.
I was going to say it's also a big
bowhunter,
but something about that movie.
Like when,
who was the guy who was getting fucked
when they squealed like a pig?
What was his name?
The actor?
Yes.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Ned beatty.
Thank you.
Got damn good actor.
Holy shit.
You were so scared for him.
Well,
uh,
what's his face?
Did it later on in the movie?
Was it.
Who was the other actor that didn't
another.
Maybe later on.
Was it fiction or Bruce Willis?
Nah,
he got caught and he's down there.
He's like,
we're never going to talk about this
again.
right?
What was that?
Pulp fiction.
But because the gap came out.
yeah,
yeah.
That was what it was.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
We're never going to talk about this.
This didn't happen.
Do you think quinn tanti would come on?
Yeah,
for sure.
What?
He's got that new movie coming out.
Definitely wins this new movie coming
out.
I think they're either just wrapping,
filming it right now or it's like
they're getting close to.
Maybe they just finished.
On a scale of one to 10,
how high do you think he's willing to
get blast off?
Why not?
Let's see.
Does doesn't?
I know that he doesn't,
but he does.
What else is he going to do?
You go through life pretending.
Just come in and talk about movies.
He loves movies.
Good.
Me too.
I love his movies.
It's 3:10.
Should we wrap this bitch up?
I don't know man.
What do you got?
I'm trying to see if any of my social
crap is.
Don't look at that stuff.
Listen,
might something good to talk about.
You introduced to a new dimension of
social media within the last three hours
and I suggest you leave your phone alone
much more often.
I wAs just checking to see if they gave
us anything good.
Talk about.
They definitely didn't.
It's three hours and 10 minutes.
I'm squeezing my bladder tight.
Well,
how do we end it?
We just.
and it.
Yeah,
definitely.
Number seven,
jihad to everyone.
Thank you to you all.
Thanks for everybody for listening to
this podcast.
A gas monkey,
apparel and clothing,
gas monkey,
garage.com gas monkey,
garage.com.
That television shell,
tell them when fast and loud on monday
nights coming in june right now we got
garage rehab on tuesday nights.
Uh,
ms.at garage would be comIng back out.
Demolition theater.
I have a lot of shows on tv,
dvr motherfuckers.
It's your friend.
He used that dvr.
Can they get it on netflix or anywhere
else?
they get it anywhere,
man.
Everywhere else.
It's like a,
the number one automotive motorcycle
thing going on.
Number one bitches.
I love it.
I had a great fucking time.
Thank you brother.
It was really,
really fun.
For sure.
All right,
thank you buddy.
Bye.